e
uh please rise for the salute to the
flag yes please join with me in a pledge
to our flag I pledge Alle
flag States of
America rep for it stands what nation
under
all all
business House Bill 301 that's for a
different Bill anyone else uh any other
pink
up
avard how you doing morning everybody
the floor is
yours for the record on Senator Kevin
aard I represent District
12 and I am the prime sponsor of this
bill and this bill basically is uh the
Genesis of uh of this bill basically
came out of of a previous study that we
had in uh last summer and it had to do
with the
landfills and what we discovered with
the information with the landfills is
that you know there's there's water
issues there's potential water issues
around the state whether it's past uh
whether it's uh Rising Tides uh number
of issues that are are affecting our
water system so you know I brought up in
in the committee I said hey so what do
we thought what do we think about having
a plan B maybe something to have in case
there is a natural disaster
or there's some nefarious acts that is
that are going on and that contaminates
our wells um I don't think I have to
tell you that we have issues with Waters
around around the state whether it's up
north there's arsenic there's pasas
marac and a number of different areas so
uh we just thought about maybe uh
introducing uh a
study a study just to look at the the
possibilities of a desalinization plant
around the Sea Coast and it it doesn't
necessarily have to be a desalinization
plan it could be an osmosis plan or
something around the state so we have an
alternative resource in case something
bad happens and so it's just a study I
would recommend I I noticed that uh it
says three Senators I would ask that we
just change it to one member of the
Senate if that's okay just
to make it if if you can make that a
committee Amendment but um that's really
the yes of of this you know we uh we
definitely need uh to look at I think
other resources and I think California
is just starting to look at it so uh
study willing to take any questions each
might have okay all right just this the
bill says two members of the Senate oh
you know what my copy on this is as
amended right i' still ask you know one
would be great I think one I'm I'm I'm
cons happy with one if you'll give me
me I would hope so yeah and and and I
like to when I do have a study I do like
to generate something that's useful um I
don't even necessarily have to agree but
at least we get the conversation going
uh I think that's that's the wonderful
thing about what happened here we had uh
pretty much a a controversial uh topic
with the landfills I I think you can all
agree with that and out of it we we
learned some things that uh we could all
come to the table with and look at each
other in the eye and say you know we did
a good job researching what what we had
and this is one of the things that I I
just considered kind of thinking outside
the box do we need one now probably not
will we need one in the future who knows
but we can we can look into that so I I
like to generate useful and practical
information uh when it comes to it
study thank you is there any questions
by members of the committee
and thank you Mr chair and thank you
senator for taking my question we
received a letter from commissioner
Scott at Dees and he mentioned that
there's an ongoing commission looking at
long-term needs at the Sea Coast um do
you think it might be helpful to get
their report before we implement this
study committee uh not necessarily I
think again one of the neat things about
having a study is that you can uh we can
do our own research yes there's a lot of
work that's going on that was brought up
in testimony and they came and they
talked about that I don't want to
interrupt what they're doing uh but at
the same time um I like to hit the
ground running and if I can glean things
and if if a desalinization plant uh was
something that they they kind of ruled
out we can always look at osmosis or we
can look at other other forms where we
can uh uh have at the ready um uh for
legislation for the next session if
somebody else wants to take the the rein
on that but um you know I I don't want
to be looking oh we should have done
something you know this is more again
it's a conversation that's one of the
things about that's beautiful about a
study and it brings both sides together
you know I like I like a little bit of
bipartisan thing going on here so that's
uh that um we won't interrupt their work
yes there's something that's going on
that's great and there's all forms of uh
uh of individuals that are engaged in
this conversation I just want I want us
to be engaged with it as well oh okay
just a followup Mr follow okay so did
you have any conversations with people
at Dees prior to they came and testify
yes oh okay yeah okay all right thank
you very much absolutely representative
Donnelly thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question uh have you had
any inspiration from other um I'll say
either countries or some of the islands
that have done desalinization um have
you had any are there other outside of
the United States opportunities for you
to be looking at this to see what your
um inspiration is on this particular
study well what's kind of cool I'm just
sitting in the in the hall waiting to
come in here and I'm talking to one of
the lobbyists who happened to uh uh know
about a particular thing that's
happening in Saudi Arabia and theyve
been doing this for years and of course
we know that if you've been to Aruba
they have that and lo and behold Star
Island I don't know if you know where
the uh uh Star Island is here in New
Hampshire the ISA schs they have a
little one uh but which is kind of cool
uh and I know that uh California hasn't
really done it now they're starting to
look at it or they're starting to do it
um I I'd like to see what they have to
do with Saudi Arabia obviously Israel
they a lot of the areas South Africa
they've done it where water is precious
it's actually more precious than gold so
I don't want to take for granted that we
are we have you know the Lakes Region we
have all these aquifers that are around
but something happens um not trying to
be paranoid but you know we discover
about a leak Cobain you know uh the
landfills and
uh I don't want to be caught
flat-footed you know so looking at all
those other other states would be
wonderful to to look at them and bring
in you know what they have to what they
have to offer what we can consider for
New Hampshire and like I said it doesn't
have to necessarily be
desalinization but that's that's the
springboard what we're going to stop
start
with okay representative ghou
representative
Simpson representative gold actually she
uh touched upon the uh the issue I had
but of the countries Israel and the
other countries doing it yeah I think
it's important to consider what other
other other have done uh again we have
our own departments looking into this uh
but let's you know if if we need to put
some legislation into uh to encourage uh
something in the future who knows what
you know what can happen in the next six
months or or two years whatever um we'll
be ready okay just remember folks you
mentioned all these islands no trips no
field trips to aru like that
representative simps I don't mind if you
put it into the language I will
definitely endorse it
budget representative Simpson thank you
Mr chair representative um I was looking
at the membership the potential
membership of the committee and um
wondering if you've talked to any
members of the senate or the house who
are in the Sea Coast region especially
that have Coastline um because I'm
thinking some of the big issues would
likely be like placement and how to deal
with byproducts and all of that sort of
thing there brackish water was an issue
that Senator alsa did bring up she is on
on the Sea Coast uh again we you know
the initial part was the Sea Coast but
it could be anywhere around the state
whether it's osmosis or anywhere it it
doesn't necessarily have to be at the
Sea Coast like I said it's just a
springboard uh but um yes uh I she was
she was concerned because of the
Department's already doing a lot of work
on this and that's fine I think I think
it's great but I think again if
you get a a number of independent Minds
in a room talking uh about this
particular topic could be osmosis it
could be something else we can glean
from other areas we can bring it to the
Departments they can say yes this works
this doesn't work and uh go from there I
know our submarines have
uh uh desalinization in them so it's
kind of
cool
yeah representative Veil
thank you Mr chair um thank you senator
for coming in and presenting today I
just have one question about okay so
it's I'm on line 10 the possibility of
putting a desalination plan in New
Hampshire including an assessment of
cost and benefits um so I'm looking at
this um the scope of what is there and
it's not very specific and what I would
be looking to have considered would be
economic impacts and environmental
impacts we can tease that out in the
study for sure absolutely thank you for
the
question representative rung for uh wait
minut excuse me representative Darby for
the first time then representative BR
thank you Mr chair thank you senator for
taking my question I'm also from nasua
um I understand you represent more than
nashaa but I you've talked a couple of
times about osmosis plants um as option
but the the study the the language in
the bill specifically says desalination
so if you're if you're thinking about
this as um as used in other areas of the
state other than the Sea Coast should
the language of the bill be broader than
just desalination I'm open to that okay
thank you you know in NASA years ago
when I was a kid um Liv on 14 Harbor
Avenue and uh which is about like half a
mile maybe a quarter a mile from the
marac
River and I loved fish and the Nashville
River emptied into the marac
river and uh I I I used to see some
things coming out of the sewers going
right into the uh and I still like the
fish so whatever I saw was not pleasant
coming out of the pipes into the miramac
and clean water uh you I still wouldn't
eat a fish from there as as much
progress as we had made just just
because of what I've seen but we've come
a long way if you will but uh you know
that that's always been in the back of
my mind and then you hear uh whether
there's arsenic there's well poisoning
from from uh U landfills or there's uh
Industrial Waste and just got to
thinking you know may maybe we should
start thinking about something that uh
could be a plan B thinking kind of
outside the box so that's but um I'm
willing I'm open to uh you know if you
want to augment it to any you you know
other fors very happy to do
so
yeah thank you Mr chair and thank you
again senator for taking my question in
response to representative Donley's
question and and also representative
Darby you mentioned that you're open to
Amendment um at noon today the EPA is is
having a press conference in marac
announcing the establishment of mcl's
for six past molecules and I was having
a discussion with colleagues about the
impact this is going to have on local
Municipal Water Systems and the need for
them to uh construct gak filters
granulated activated carbon to remove
past because the the the the limits are
very low um so would you be open to
having this bill be amended to not just
look at desalination but also any water
treatment to enable Municipal Water
Regulation well there you go you're
thinking outside the box okay and that's
kind of the thing that we'll do in the
study but yes I'd be absolutely and and
those are some of the things that I love
about a study that we can we can
consider stuff like that I think that's
a great idea okay just one quick
followup um you mentioned osmosis and
desalination as a disclaimer I used to
have a business called filmtech in my
business portfolio when I worked for a
large corporation and they're the world
leader in desalination as far as I know
it's always reverse osmosis and
nanofiltration so um I'd be curious to
see if there's other ways of
desalinating on a commercial scale that
would have other technology but if you
ever go out to film Tech they're in a
Minnesota and it was always a great trip
for me cuz it was just like three blocks
from the Mall of
America so but you know
we can talk offline too if you want to
talk more about that kind of technology
and I think what you're seeing right now
just even in our conversation is is the
give and take of of ideas and and what
the study can do and uh if nothing else
we can we can bring to the awareness
around the state uh the need uh for
clean water and for situations where you
know we we we got to take a little pay a
little more attention to it
so representative wolf for a question is
there enough time thank you for taking
my question absolutely is there enough
time with all of these ideas to do the
study and complete it I'm really good at
studies okay you got to realize folks
this is just
anything yeah okay yeah and we'll have
recommendations and and and whatnot and
uh um I I like to pick brains and I like
to see what uh what things we can come
up with and it's useful great if we we
find that we can't do anything that's
also
useful Harvey Bo and then representative
par okay real quick thank you very much
thank you for bringing up this uh
legislation Senator avart and I was just
wondering if it would be accurate to say
that maybe um two two things if if the
chair will indulge me if this
legislation
is more like a let's see how we can
improve improve Municipal Water
Supply um since it probably doesn't
pertain to all the people on Wells up
north um because I don't assume that a
desalinization plant at the coast would
be piping up to Points North and second
part if you don't mind um do you know of
any uh reverse osmosis that's already
going on in Municipal Water Supply
plants thanks uh locally no I do not
know if there are any and I'd like to
enter main that if if that's a
possibility I do know that as far as
distribution that is definitely uh
something that the Departments did come
up and say you know that that there is
an issue with that so uh like I said it
you know we this is a springboard and
and we can we can entertain thoughts of
uh you know if we needed that extra
water supply uh how would uh we go about
Distributing it and
whatnot so you know getting back to the
landfill it
we we were just trying to figure out how
we can reduce the landfill now I know
we're talking about osmosis and then you
know we were talking about you know how
it water just kept coming up over and
over and over and over again uh with the
landfill
build and uh we realize that we can
actually reduce the tonnage by 2third if
we incinerate like like Massachusetts
does uh Western Massachusetts
incinerates a lot and with that
incineration they also uh Power they use
it for for energy an energy resource and
they power their water treatment
plant that's kind of cool uh it's
One-Stop shopping
now you know now you got to weigh the
balance well if we incinerate there's
air pollution if we put it in the ground
there's contamination of water but you
know we got scrubbers we got technology
if we desalinized we there's this
brackish system situations but I'm not
taking no for an answer as far as you
know can we come up with something
that'll work for New Hampshire you know
so
um uh I I don't know of anything locally
that's doing it there might be again we
can tease that out in the study okay
representative harb then rep representa
Ryan and I want to say one thing uh
we've had a week or so off but more than
half the committee has asked a question
so uh you know cool it
down I like you
don't representative harb representative
thank you senator for taking my question
uh my question is this why did you pick
a committee over a commission where I've
sat on some commissions and then you can
have other stakeholders involved not
that I'm against members of the house
and the Senate but if this is such an
important issue
um why didn't you move for a commission
and then put a number of stakeholders on
just a question thank thank you for that
question but as
as as a legislator I I I know
commissions
work and commissions can continue and
continue and continue a study we can at
least my experience in every study that
I've done and I'll I'll have a couple
more coming up on energy uh um this year
I got a small time frame I can make
suggestions and if we want to build a
commission from that point on that's
great but it's it's like I said it's a
spring board
uh I don't mean to be
insulting at all but um the department
of bureaucracy can work very slowly at
times and I I think uh just from my
experience uh handling something like
this
uh I I have a track record of being
being able to produce something that's
useful and uh for everybody and so
that's uh you know I guess some of that
lays on me um but I I um I guess I would
have to ask you to trust me to move move
the conversation and if if it turns out
that we need a commission or we can
augment an already existing commission
white if the state ends up in a major
emergency or disaster as you say which
is what we're we're preparing for don't
you think the federal government would
be
involved and probably would supersede
either way uh they could uh but we've
had a train Rick out in the Midwest and
that that water situation hasn't really
uh been resolved yet
any any other uh questions by members of
the committee seeing none you very much
thank you all I really appreciate your
deers
good
morning for the record my name is Ted
deers and I'm the assistant director of
The Water Division at the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services and
uh you received a letter this morning in
your email but I printed out a copy for
you to have here at the hearing and
mostly I just want to spend a couple of
minutes uh maybe addressing some of the
questions that already came up to the
senator and just to brag a little bit on
stuff we're already doing um along these
lines just so that you have some
awareness of that so if you'll indulge
me for just a couple of minutes um the
the issue of desalinization really
hasn't been looked at in depth since the
N since the early 2000s there was a
study uh looking at uh something in
Seabrook sort of coordinated with the uh
nuclear power plant to see if there was
a way to make that economical at that
point it was not um so so this hasn't
been looked at I would say in depth for
for uh some significant period of time
time the work that we're primarily
engaged in at this point around the
state relative to you know sort of water
supply and kind of the emergency
situation that uh representa or that
Senator avard was talking about and
again his take on this is a little
different from I think the current work
that's going on which is really looking
towards the current needs um and and
also of course some of the issues that
have been raised by some of the future
needs regulatory you know and otherwise
um is that we've really been focused on
interconnection uh one of the big
studies that we did in the southern part
of the state identified that uh we have
plenty of water it just isn't where we
kind of need it and so the idea is
really to look at uh the distribution um
how you interact with the distribution
of different kinds of treatment types of
where the water goes and how it's needed
and where it's going to be needed in the
future and so those have been the
primary focus and you've seen some of
those bills and there's bills that you
you know there are probably still on on
the docket yet to for you to see you
know things related to say the the water
pipe underneath the miramac down in
Lichfield or Hudson and you know some of
these things that you've already seen
come across uh your your desks so and
the same is true going on right now in
the C Coast we have a study that will be
done sort of later in 2024 early 2025
which which does do exactly the same
thing which looks at what's current
water supply capacity what are the W
water demands you know what is actually
being used um doing some design
Alternatives analysis of different ways
of doing interconnection and water
supply understanding the the situation
which is I think achieving almost Epic
Proportions uh among small water
suppliers so these small water supply
systems are becoming increasingly
non-economic to run understanding how we
try to connect some of those and get
some of those
Consolidated and really looking at
Regional cooperation of where there's
water and how that moves around in a
different area looking at the funding
what would it cost to do some of these
things what would a cost to supply some
of these and you know understanding um
you know with some techn having some
some technical memos uh so that you can
understand exactly what would be needed
and some of the sort of conceptual plans
for how it could be
provided that's a little different than
I think what Senator avard is looking at
which is sort of coming up with sort of
this planb approach but it is fit within
the information that you would need to
understand in terms of what is the need
where is the need how is it currently
supplied and what does it cost to do the
kinds of things that we're already doing
or need to do that is already being
looked at and will be available sometime
after this commission uh would or the
committee uh would finish its work the
only other thing that I would want to
point out is that um we there somebody
asked the question about whether or not
there's any uh reverse osmosis going on
in any municipalities I would just note
and it was also brought up about
landfills is the turnkey uh landfill in
Rochester does actually have an RO plant
a reverse osmosis plant that it sends
its lead shap through and that was
really because of the recalcitrant
nature of nitrogen within their effluent
so basically they leachates weird stuff
um and it's not well treated in current
sometimes it's not well treated
depending the constituency of it in
modern wastewater treatment plants and
so Rochester was a have a bit of a hard
time with that product so they put on
two reverse osmosis I think there's
something like half a million gallons a
day that they're actually treating um as
part of their as part of their permits
so as a as a for those of you who
followed the trials and tribulations of
Great Bay um it uh was a huge Boon to
reducing nitrogen coming out of the
kacho river um as as a result of the
that that Improvement and was a major
Improvement for the entire
Estuary I have no other thing else to
say except that if you have any
like is an a
veil thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
deers so I'm just looking at the
situation where we were talking about um
what goes on in the landfill and
incineration and water quality and my
understanding is that if it goes up in
the air it can wind up in the water is
that the case well certainly what goes
up must come down um whether it comes
down here or somewhere else that's
really for the air people to understand
that's pretty technical um because it
depends on lots and lots and lots of
factors and you know I think that this
is not my a of expertise but I would
imagine that there was be all kinds of
pollution reduction Technologies
associated with anything like that so um
yeah I mean but but certainly this and
then you have to do something with the
residuals so what what do you do with
the ash what do you do with the fly ash
what do you do with the ash that comes
out of the scrubbers um that they take
out all that pollution all of that has
to go somewhere and that's you know can
become you know more of a problem than
the actual problem if you don't have a
good plan on how to do that so there's a
lot to think about uh with any of those
Technologies representative Derby thank
you Mr chair thank you Mr de for taking
my question the senator brought up the
trained dment in East Palestine Ohio and
the water pollution how would the um how
would New Hampshire Dees respond if
there was such a a um such a travesty in
New Hampshire um for um Municipal Water
Supplies it's a great question and you
know I'm we certainly have all of our
Municipal Water Supplies have emergency
action plans and we approve those
emergency action plans as part of their
annual or sometimes three every three
year depending on who you are um their
sanitary surveys so this is something
that is part and parcel of what water
systems are required to do we're also
now starting to see EPA have some
requirements for those kinds of
emergency situations with wastewater
treatment plants as well so there is a
lot of preparation going on for those
kinds of events and we have I think one
of the best in the nation spill response
you know programs um and so we have you
know people who are trained we have
people who who exercise on a regular
basis we have spills all the time in
this state and we respond all the time
in this state um you know you can't
prepare for everything and so there's
you know if something truly catastrophic
would happen it would be a full court
press from all resources across the
state um and that would be handled
agency
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you um Mr deers again
um so I'm looking at this study and the
date for the reporting out of is
November 1st of this year um if we were
to augment this would we want Dees to be
on this study and to contribute
information thank thank you for asking I
think we're certainly willing to
contribute information whether we sit on
a committee or not um so it I would say
that we would be if we were to be named
into a commission and especially if we
were to to be given some sort of a
leadership role on it we would probably
have concerns about uh Staffing
Resources is but but in terms of
providing
information you want us we we'll be
Dar anyone else question by anyone
else representa thank you very much um
real quick the what was the uh bill that
the the other study that you referenced
you have the bill number the or the name
of it or I'm sorry I'm not sure which
which one the one you're the one you
were telling us that is already underway
to study the water oh this is the study
that we're doing is under is under the
um the the SE the the seast commission
on long-term goals and requirements for
drinking water this was a commission
that was created in
2019 and it's needs it's supposed to
complete all of its work by
2029 um and there they do have annual
reports of that committee I'm happy to
people you
bet any other questions by members of
the
committee seeing none thank you very
much excellent have a great
day uh we have no other pink
cards see no no one else here to to send
in a pink card clear the
301 and we're starting again 10 minutes
break
e
345 Senator Murphy floor is yours thank
you Mr chairman it's great to be back in
front of so many colleagues from the
house good to see you all again uh my
name is Keith Murphy I'm the senator for
District 16 which is Manchester's W one
towns of Goffstown hooks at candy and
Raymond um the Genesis of this bill was
that I received a call from a
constituent last summer and she said
Senator
Murphy I have been trying to take my
kids to Kingston State Park and
sometimes I go online and I can't make a
reservation because it's booked and
sometimes I can and when I go the
parking lot is always full full
overwhelmingly full with cars from other
states and I don't think it's fair that
New Hampshire residents can't go to the
park because we're basically booked out
of it and I said well let me look into
that and so I not living too far from
Kingston myself decided to try that and
the first time I went online it was
booked and then I booked for the next
week and I went and sure enough the
parking lot was probably
75% out of state
plates well maybe it was a family
reunion or something it was a one-off so
I tried it again a few weeks later and
it was the same thing
if you look at page three of this AAL
page document that I handed
out there's a chart with labeled
Kingston visitation 2023 by day and the
paragraphs Kingston State Park saw 49%
of his visitation from reservations last
season meaning they were made
online of those reservations 57% were
from out of state 43 from inate during
the five peak days reservations were
sold out I find it surprising that it's
only five but during the five that uh
they were sold out demographic shift was
67% out of state 33% in
state so I didn't think this was fair I
agreed with the constituent these are
parks that are owned by New Hampshire
residents they're owned by our citizens
and they should have some degree of
priority or some degree of preference
2third of Park visitors being of State
while we turn away inate residents did
not strike me as fair and
Equitable so I filed the bill and what
the bill says basically is Park fees
continue to be set by legislative
fiscal
but where there are Park entry fees the
fees can be no more than 50% for instate
than they are for out of state and my
thinking wasn't that we would lower the
instate Park fees it's that we would
raise the outof state park fees and the
reason for that is if you look at the
single piece of paper here's a nice
little
graph nice little chart that spells out
what other states do to
us and I specifically want to point out
Massachusetts Park entry
fees $5
to8 for residents non-residents meaning
we go to visit their state parks 20 to
$30 other states are doing this to us
but we treat everybody regardless of
where they come from at $4 they get in
the park
$4 my understanding is that fee has not
changed in over a decade so the park
fees are due for a
revision I want to talk for a second
about the Senate
hearing there was no opposition at the
Senate
hearing
and DNR came in and said we're not oppos
the bill we're neutral on the bill but
then they had a lot of reasons out the
blue why they oppose the
bill maybe you've been to hearings and
sat in hearings like that we're not
oppos the bill but and I want to address
a couple of things that I
note second paragraph it says that the
department States the impact the state
park fund is expected to result in a
decrease in
Revenue okay well that doesn't sound
good but if you look at the next
paragraph bullet point
one visitation data from 2023 would
remain the same with
999,000 and I'm going to try to
summarize a bit visitors in fiscal year
39% from residents 61% from
non-residents so you know that's that 6
61% you go to the next page the division
assumed the maximum decrease of 50% in
day use fees bringing the average fees
from 450 to 225 for instate now I I
never suggested and I don't think
anybody ever suggested that the fees
would go from 450 to 225 that number was
sort of just pulled out of their
heads but even if that's what we did
even if that's what legislative fiscal
did it would be an increase in
Revenue because the very next line very
next bullet point is conversly division
assumed an increase of 1.5 times for the
non-resident adult fee increasing it to
four from 450 to
675 this change would would result in an
increase in State Park revenue uh of
1366 million well 1366 million minus the
loss they talking about of 860,000 still
means an increase in Revenue over a half
million
so even with their numbers that they
pulled out of their head without talking
to anybody in legislative
fiscal it's more money
and I just want to reiterate this is a
this is a legislative decision this is
not a decision that should be made by
the department they have input there
legislative fiscal committee for a
reason that's where they bring their
opinions to when it comes to these fees
um and I'll conclude here Mr
chairman just want to make sure I got
all the points I wanted to
make the department is mandated to be an
run as an Enterprise fund what that
means is that it should Maxim maximiz
business businesses take care of their
owners now I'm happy that I own a
restaurant when I order a burger at my
restaurant I don't pay for my burger I
pay for it and then I purchase the food
that's used to make it and I pay for it
in the way that I I pay for the employee
who cooks it for me but I don't pay a
bill at the end of it well our parks are
owned by the people who live here and
why are we pay why are we charging them
the same fee as we charging somebody
park now there was one red herring
argument that came up and I want to talk
about that just for one second and that
is
well we're going to reprogram the
website we're going to have to have the
person at the at the front gate uh check
the IDS and and identify every single
person walking you know coming in in the
car that's a red herring because the
bill is very simple and it says that
state that license plates are good
enough if a car pulls up and it's got
four people in it and the car has a
Massachusetts plate it's an out ofor if
the car drives up and it's got New
Hampshire plates that's an instate
resident car the the it's not meant to
be more work for anybody and that's why
it's drafted be very Broad and how it
identifies inst State versus out of
state so that concludes my comments Mr
chairman I appreciate the opportunity
there's any questions I'm happy to take
them
representative
Morgan thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my
question we're talking about rates here
uh your initial issue was that the
individual from New Hampshire was
trouble getting
bookings what have we done for the
individual who is not getting a booking
regardless of what the cost is where's
the solution to that problem thank you
thank you for the question the laws of
Economics say that if you charge more
for something you'll have less demand
for it ideally there'd be some more
openings for people from New Hampshire
truthfully I think that if the fees were
set at $4 and $8 that wouldn't drive
anybody
away so perhaps the answer is more
Parkland or open up the reservation
system and allow more people to enter I
will say that on the days that I did go
to Kingston there was plenty of parking
spaces there maybe the reservation
numbers are set a bit
low but I ideally there'd be a few maybe
a few less out of state residents or out
of state visitors but more spaces for
New Hampshire visitors I don't think $8
is going to send anybody away no one
that was going to come here for $4 in my
opinion is going to say well we're going
to go to new H Massachusetts parks
Because by the way they're charging
their residents $8 anyway so if they
were going to come to uh Massachusetts
or New Hampshire they still
will I hope I answered your
question
thank you have a
followup or a followup
yeah so again we're talking about money
but the problem is with the bookings is
there a way to give the New Hampshire
resident uh some sort of priority in
making the bookings that would give them
the advantage over an out estator coming
in and tying up a slot I understand the
question the easiest answer in my
opinion would simply to say that out of
the let's say we're looking at Kingston
right which has
a capacity
of reservation capacity is 385 people
simplest thing to do would be to say
well the first 150 or 200 spots would be
reserved for New Hampshire residents and
because when you go to the website you
enter your plate number and your state
of residence for that plate right so you
could say the first 150 or 200 spases
pick a number um would not be available
for out of state residents that would
save those spaces for New Hampshire
people
the downside to that is you know I'm
very cognizant of the fact that we want
people to visit from out of state we
don't necessarily want them to not be
able to come on a day that isn't
busy um you know New Hampshire
businesses do benefit from having people
come in from from other places so I
would say that if the number was going
to be set that way and Reserve those
spaces for New Hampshire residents it
would have to be done at a at a fairly
low
number so it's not to deter out of state
visitors thank you thank you Mr chair
anyone else representative rung thank
you Mr chair and thank you senator for
taking my question we often get bills in
this committee about changing fee
structure and there was actually a bill
in state and federal this year that
would give a discount to retired
military people and I get the sense and
I and I want to know if you share it
that we're dealing with this peace meal
and and you've brought up a very
important point about residents versus
non-residents but do you think it might
be a good idea to have this our whole
fee structure for all our Parks really
looked in in a comprehensive way because
what if somebody comes from out of state
but they're retired military and maybe
disabled you know it seems like there's
so many different factors we're putting
into the soup that we really it's really
difficult to see the big picture and
where the state parks you mentioned it
in your testimony that we really have
they're operated as an
Enterprise that maybe we we should
really take a bird's eyye view of all of
our fees all of our parks to see the
best mix that provides uh Financial
stability for the division thank you for
the question uh I will tell you ma'am
that I I spent a significant amount of
time going over all the park fees for
all the New England states Maine this
big thick packet
Massachusetts this is Vermont oh look
this is also Vermont and this probably
25 Pages here so I I certainly agree
with you in that this is a very complex
issue fees are very much due for
updating they are have not kept pace
anywhere near inflation I think if you
apply the inflation to the fee of $4 in
2012 I think you'd see it would probably
more than double um and I would not like
to see Park fees doubled for New
Hampshire residents because frankly they
already face enough of a budget issue at
home as it is yes I think it is time to
take a wholesale look at the fee
structure but until the legislature does
that and maybe buet does a study
committee and and goes through that
whole process this is a nice simple one
paragraph solution um that may be a
Band-Aid but it's better than leaving it
at four hours for yet another
year followup Mr chair or followup would
you support an amendment that would
establish a study committee so so we can
get going on it right
away with maybe a couple Senators a few
representatives to we just had the
Senate come back we just heard a bill to
from a senator about setting up a study
committee but maybe you know spending
the summer doing exactly what you
described and coming forth in the fall
with a bill that looks at everything in
totality because yes this is this is a
quick fix but it's going to require some
changes new sign signage new information
if we're going to go through that
process why not do it for all the the
the all the fee
structure that's the will of the
committee I'll certainly respect it and
I would serve on that committee uh I
will say that on my side of the wall
that we're not too fond of committees uh
study committees in general because we
get we each get put on three or four of
them well I think I can get Senator avar
to support this one we'll do a little
yeah
just a just for this bill is one of the
uh is a early bill so we have to make a
decision on what we do by in two weeks
so uh it's it's not one where we can
spend we have a we don't have a big time
for for a question thank you thank you
Mr chair and thank you for bringing this
bill forward Senator um I think this
chart of the comparison with the other
New England Park fees is very telling
and um I I I don't think I gathered when
do you think I'm I'm surprised we
haven't done anything yet if you have
any idea why we haven't updated our fees
and when was the last time we updated
our fees if you mentioned it I missed it
thanks my understanding is that it's
been over a decade I don't want to speak
for the Department um I believe that
they have said to me that they are
looking at the fees and would propose
that they're going to be changed through
joint fiscal committee you know in the
near future I I don't want to put words
in their mouths however so um I agree
that they are very much due for an
update I also think that when we do it
if we don't do it with this bill it is
imperative that we look very closely at
what other states are charging us and
then if they're charging us more we do
them representative Derby for a question
thank you Mr chair thank you senator for
taking my question um the language of
the bill talks about um entrance to
state parks um New Hampshire state parks
are are widely varied and include um
some ski location SK Resorts like um
Mount sop and Canon Mountain that are
based on tickets as opposed to um you
know that's that's how you sort of gain
entrance and so my my question is is
would it include those facilities and
would it um uh and have you thought
about using the language that other um
passes I would certainly welcome the
change to day pass language but it would
not be included if you look at the bill
the second line of the new text is the
commissioner of the department may elect
to set separate fee
schedules for res residents and
non-residents for specific uses within
the
park so you don't pay a fee at the gate
to
enter you know Cannon you pay when you
buy the lift ticket that is that is a
specific fee so you know if I go to
Kingston and I rent a
canoe I pay a fee for that that is a use
so this allows the commissioner the
discretion to set a separate fee
structure if he or she chooses but it
doesn't require them to do so because I
recognize that it may not make sense in
every
case any other question representative W
looking at these fees of thank you for
taking the question Excuse me yes
um you think this will necessarily
decrease the usage of these Parks or
will we get more out of state residents
in there taking up the spots I
understand I don't believe it will
it certainly will not lead to more out
ofate residents it may lead to slightly
less some people some small percentage
may be deterred by the fee going from $4
to8 as I told the other representative I
don't think that's likely to be the case
I think it's likely to stay all just
about the
same in a way again I would be happy to
see a few less out of state visitors
visiting the parks um because that would
mean more space for New Hampshire
residents which was of course why the
place for a followup but the park system
is a self-funded agency so if we get an
overall decrease in Revenue that's going
to
hurt I think there's 0% chance of that
happening I am extremely confident of
that even using the
numbers provided by the agency in which
they predicted that we would they
assumed incorrectly in my opinion that
we will lower the fee from 450 to 225
for instate residents but increase out
of sters from 450 to 675 even if we did
that it would generate more than a half
million dollars in new
revenue and I did not in any way shape
or form suppose or recommend that the
fee would be cut for in inate residents
I think it set at $4 where it has been
for over a decade we went to$ four and8
let's run those
numbers
I think it's going to be significantly
more
Revenue questions by anyone
else representative
Haley thank you for taking my question U
getting back to representative of
organ's uh question about capacity I
think the easiest way to control the
capacity is let in-state residents
Reserve
earlier and then let the out of state
residents two days or a week later
that's probably the best way to control
capacity that's how a lot of places
control capacity for you know concerts
or anything else and I think that's the
way you should be looking at that's a
solid recommendation and that's one I
would endorse I also want to say that in
the Senate we don't typically get a lot
of questions when we introduce bills
it's it's heartening for me and a good
flashback for me to be in front of the
house again where I I get actual
questions
yeah we got time to
there recognizes Brian
Wilson from natural cultural resources
Park good morning
everyone morning Mr chairman uh my name
is Brian Wilson I'm the division
director for the division of parks and
recreation in the department of natural
and cultural resources um I'd like to
read my uh testimony which I submitted
through the uh portal uh to the
committee um in in full and um so bear
with me while I read through that I
think it's important um and then um I
will want to uh uh follow up on uh some
of the things that I heard uh here
already today just to um help um I think
clarify some things uh Dear Mr chairman
uh Ren Zulo and committee and members of
the committee please accept this
testimony on behalf of the Department of
Natural and cultural resources division
of Park and Recreation regarding SB 345
relative to State Park fees for State
residents the division opposes this bill
and believes that it would have a
substantial adverse impact on tourism
the visitor experience and could result
in a decrease in revenue for the state
park fund the division has been working
on a a calibration of our fee schedules
across the park system in consultation
with the fiscal committee this has been
a multi-year project dating back to 2018
and it involves our state park advisory
Council the first set of fe uh package
uh changes that were approved by the
fiscal committee recently were in
September of 2023 uh relative to uh
Canon mountains uh lift tickets the
second was uh approved in April of 2023
uh relative to the parking meters at the
Sea Coast uh beaches where we charge an
hourly rate and uh most recently the
committee approved the for our camping
and lodging in December of
2023 the last significant piece of our
fee package is the dayuse fish fees
which we have already begun to examine
in anticipation of making a request to
fiscal within the next year this bill
has the potential to financially disrupt
the careful planning and budgeting done
by both the division and the fiscal
committee to ensure that fees are
balanced and provide the necessary
funding to operate the park system
further it binds our ability to
currently in statute to adjust our fees
according to market conditions and to
create a mandatory by creating a
mandatory doubling of cost to
non-residents by way of background the
state park fund was established in 1991
creating an operationally self-funded
Park
system the House Appropriations
Committee report that recommended the
passage uh uh recommended passage wrote
this bill establishes the New Hampshire
State Park and ski areas as an
Enterprise type self-funded accountable
business entity to provide improved Park
and ski Recreation facilities and
services to New Hampshire citizens and
tourists alike the fee approval process
through the joint legislative fiscal
committee uh pursuant to RSA 216 a3g was
established to provide the department
with the ability to maximize revenues
and adjust fees according to market
conditions and Trends as is common in
Private
Industry it further states that fees for
the use of campgrounds and ski lifts
shall be comparable with fees for use of
similar privately owned facilities the
operation of all Enterprise functions
shall be as profitable as possible
within the purposes of the park
system the division continually strives
to balance its priorities by examining
fee structures visitation data market
conditions and other metrics to inform
recommendations to the fiscal committee
for adjustments to park fees we're very
concerned concerned that this bill would
put into law a
50% um uh discount or uh double the fees
which would um have adverse impacts
here um an online reservation system was
put into place in 2019 to specifically
address Park capacity concerns um and
has been well received by visitors
across the park
system prior to 2019 Parks were
routinely full with many visitors being
turned away the reservations system
allows visitors to benefit by reserving
ahead of time to guarantee their spot at
the park while allowing the division to
define a specific capacity number at
each Park as well the established
reservation system was streamlined uh
has streamline the guest experience and
flow of traffic confirmation emails are
sent uh with each reservation that
includes a no before you go Section with
pertinent safety information and Rule
information where we find we have a more
informed uh visitor when they
arrive um we feel we have made
significant strides forward using the
reservation system for visitor
satisfaction Public Safety and managing
Park
resources New Hampshire's hospitality
and tourism based private businesses do
not differentiate fee structures based
on a residency on residency as is as a
common practice the state through uh the
the Department of Business and economic
Affairs spends millions of dollars in ad
campaigns to his trct out ofate visitors
approximately half of the day use
visitors at New Hampshire state parks
come from out ofate and a residency
based structure of this nature would
discourage tourism and related economic
activity thank you for the opportunity
to provide testimony and additional
information on S SP 345 and I'm happy to
uh provide any further
information questions by members of the
committee rep
representative harvy representative ran
thank thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um does the
department have any um division does the
division have any information on the um
side benefits um to the economy of
attracting um out ofate residents um for
to the parks um you know to businesses
restaurants things like that um we uh
generally rely on uh business and
economic Affairs and uh the outdoor
recreation office to uh generate
economic impact reports so there are
several that exist out there um one of
the more recent ones was uh inclusive
Within part of the uh Statewide rail
trail plan um which uh dncr uh manages
the Statewide trail system um there's
been reports of the economic impact uh
to the rail trails to the O rvu um there
was uh was a um although a little dated
now perhaps um an extensive look at um
the Redevelopment of Hampton Beach State
Park and what that would contribute uh
to uh to the Hampton Community um and
yes so I mean there's there's um lots of
reports out there both nationally and
and locally uh regarding the impact of
outdoor recreation from a from an
economic
standpoint for a followup thank you Mr
chair
um in you mentioned uh the the millions
that were spent on Advertising to
attract out of-state residents is is
some of that um not just to fund the
parks but to attract um to encourage the
you know the economic B Statewide
economic benefits um well it would it
would be really to attract the Statewide
economic benefits so you know uh we're
we're excited to you know say that we we
think we're one of the most efficient
State Park systems in the country what I
mean by that is we're operationally
self-supported so um of our $40 million
operating budget only 1% of that for our
Bureau of historic sites uh comes from
General funding all of the rest of it is
produced by people who come to visit or
camp or pay a parking fee or an
overnight camping fee so the
commissioner uh of dncr already has the
authority under statute when that system
was created that way to create our fee
structure and be able to do that uh uh
and and provide so that we can maintain
that that structure in the way that the
system system is set up as
self-sufficient so we we we pride
ourselves in in operating in that in
that uh mindset that um everything that
we look at is you know from an
analytical standpoint um a lot of the
data uh that was shared by Senator
Murphy was data that our division
produced um to follow up on questions
that he had uh relative this to this
bill and uh s we've started this
reservation system for dayuse visits a
few years ago um we now have a lot more
information at our fingertips than we
ever had before relative to who is
coming to visit where they're coming
from and and that information that we
intend to use uh as part of our own
process of going going forward so um
because the fee package is uh big and
there's a lot of uh complexity in it um
we were taking an approach of kind of
taking
um smaller bites off of it if you will
with respect to our metered parking we
did first Canon mountain is its own
separate uh piece our camping we did a
piece just just for camping and really
the the the last piece was for us to to
take a a close look at what the day use
fees um what I I also want to I think is
very important to understand too
relative to New Hampshire being self
funded is none of those surrounding
states Massachusetts Main Vermont or
anything they are not self-supported um
so they are getting getting tens and
tens of millions of dollars of general
fund support for their park system I
spoke with the director of Massachusetts
state parks relative this bill their
fees are so high there uh because a
commissioner at the time wanted to set
the fees to discourage people during
covid to come to Parks during
Massachusetts and the fees have not been
reset since um so they get complain
after complaint after complaint about
people who are from out of state why
would I have to pay $30 to come to
Walden Pond State Reservation
that's that's how they set the fee New
Hampshire is different and unique in a
way where we rely on hospitality and
tourism uh as uh one of our main
economic drivers here and the park
system is really set up uh to um to help
way representative R
you okay thank you representative R and
thank you for taking my question um I've
seen the discussion of fees on various
departments this year uh especially in
the Department of Agriculture where they
hadn't raised the fees in 15 years when
was the last time that the day fees Park
entry fees were raised sure the last
time the day use fees were raised was in
2012 so over a dozen years ago
yep and follow up for a
followup and you have within your
abilities
the right to raise the fees at your
right okay thank you got representative
run thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question Mr Wilson so you you
talked about how you've been working
kind of peac meal at different aspects
of the fee structure to address them and
bring them to the fiscal committee um
how far are you through that process
looking at the different various
segments of
fees um thank you for the question so uh
the the day use fees is really kind of
the the last uh significant piece of
Revenue um that we would be going after
so um about $4 million is can be
attributed and of our annual uh Revenue
can be attributed to deuse deuse fees um
so um that's a that's a good chunk that
we recognize um a few things one is that
uh
it it's been over a decade since those
fees were adjusted um however we've been
able to operate the park system within
our self-funding model for that time so
we're we're trying to kind of thread the
needle if you will with respect to
keeping the fees as low as possible to
encourage folks both inst State and out
of state to be able to come and enjoy
the park system but at uh um at at at
the threshold where we're able to
generate enough Revenue to to operate um
now uh other costs have gone up uh you
know for us you know relative to
Staffing and everything in the world
really uh everything that we do is more
expensive now so that's why we're you
know been taking a more concerted effort
and and tackle the campground fees which
was also the first time in 10 years that
that's been updated so that was just
done uh last uh December um so I hope
that answered your question yeah follow
up Mr chair um so do you also part of
your budget do you for any capital
reserve funding or Capital expenditures
for improvements does that come out of
your operating budget um not really I
would I would classify that as
maintenance so where um we we do a
certain level of of Maintenance and
improvements within our operating budget
um but we do rely on the cap the state
capital budget process to help uh fund
um projects that are larger and more
costly in nature in terms of whether
it's a major renovation or restoration
or something or Improvement or expansion
okay and and just one more Mr chair um
back in 2018 2019 your division came to
this committee to give like an
orientation early in the term and I
found it very helpful and I would like
to suggest that perhaps in the next
several months you know might by the end
of the year early next year you consider
doing that because what I struggle with
is we have bills like this come in and
there was a similar bill that went to
state and federal that would give a
discount to active or retired military
personnel and um it just seems kind of
disjointed so it would be helpful to
have like a presentation about all of
this and maybe it will come after your
the day fee analysis that you do but if
you could think about keeping us in the
loop about and being proactive about
communicating about your division so
that we're better informed when these
kind bills come through it would be
helpful great thank you we would love
that
opportunity for for another question
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question the
fees that are listed on this sheet I
guess that uh Senator Donovan prepared
is uh is this accurate that it's $29 for
night
camping um I don't have that in in front
of me so I'm not sure what
you're
question um yes um our our camping fee
schedule is Al also complex so I I was
hoping not to be quizzed on uh the rates
for for for the camping uh they vary
from uh primitive sites to uh full
hookup sites
um so $29 does sound like one of one of
those rate structures for for relative
to
Camping follow through with that for a
followup if it's $29 why is the instate
rate if we have problems with
capacity um so we don't really have
problems with capacity relative to uh to
our campgrounds and um differentiating
rate structures between residents and
non-residents was something that we the
department weighed when we went to um
update our camping uh fees uh last year
and we opted not to separate and and
create a differential between uh a
camping
why
they say because um yeah I it's it's
it's it's it's it's a few things is is
one is um the way that we've been
operating for quite a while now has had
the rates the same across the board
which makes implementation of that a lot
easier so if you were from out of state
and you went online to uh make a
reservation to come camping and you
would put in a bunch of information um
um what we what we see as folks will say
that they're from New Hampshire but
they're not really from New Hampshire
and they but they'll book it that way
and then we've got to re- reccon that at
the time that they arrive uh for camping
and there are quite a few very Savvy
campers out there who do this kind of
thing for a living where they'll create
several accounts with different
addresses and things like that to try to
game the system if you will um so
implementation of um verifying residency
for camping was was was something that
time is anyone else for
questions representative
G do you still have the senior discounts
for camping and uh well that's the only
one I think I know
of yes and I'm glad you asked thank you
so relative to uh the dayuse fees our
current package has several uh comps and
discounts
including uh for state
employees um for um the general court
and um for military uh for New Hampshire
disabled veterans for New Hampshire
National Guard for New Hampshire seniors
uh it is free it is not free for 65 and
older if you're out of state so there's
a whole menu within our current fee
package that allows for the opportunity
for either free or deep discounted
access for for day use uh the the state
park license plate is probably the best
example um it's a discounted season pass
uh essentially that is only able to
eligible for if you have a New Hampshire
reg registered vehicle um and then we
also have Library passes as well too at
most local libraries that anybody who
really wants to get to a park that can't
afford the fee uh can go and take that
library anyone
you
and call uh next person is uh Jim
Chase from SEO Science
post thank you thanks for uh the
opportunity to address the committee
thank you chairperson um um my name is
Jim Chase I'm the executive director of
the SEO Science Center in Ry New
Hampshire operating out of odor Point
State Park um Science Center has
operated in partnership with New
Hampshire parks for over 30 years from
our location in odor we operate under a
service agreement that obligates us to
provide interpretive Ser services within
the park to the benefit of the the
broader Community um during this time
the SEO Science Center has grown known
to be one of the largest by attendance
nonprofit cultural institutions in the
state of New Hampshire we've hosted over
two million visitors and presently see
about a 100,000 folks through our doors
every season I'm here to voice my
concerns and and express my opposition
to
345 believing it will have significant
adverse impacts to the SEO Science
Center in in terms of both reducing our
mission impact and Mission footprint in
terms of the the number of people we can
uh post every year and as well as uh
perhaps threatening our financial
stability as a smaller nonprofit
institution in our view as has been
discussed here parks would have no real
option under SB 345 other than to double
fees I've provided a brief summary
document all of you that kind of goes
through our case and thought process
both in terms of the implications on our
mission the implications to our
financial situation and and uh some
window into the logistical complications
that this would create as a partner
operating within the state
park based on 2023 admissions
data around 100,000 visitors I think we
had 98,000 visitors 43% of those folks
are from out of
state in 2023 we earned
$390,000 of admissions revenue and what
that would mean is that with 43% of
those folks coming from out of state
that puts
$160,000 of Revenue in Jeopardy should
out ofate visitors be disincentivized to
Center if in a ballpark scenario we lost
half of those out of state visitors
which I think
is perhaps a reasonable
assumption because what's happening in a
place like the science center the price
to admissions to the park and the
science center is seen by a visitor as
an aggregate fee when we calculate our
admission fees We Lay the parks fee on
top of that to come to some
understanding of the psychology of the
customer coming through the door and
what they're willing to spend for a
family of four to come and visit and
weigh that against what we feel the
value of the experience at the center is
so I think we could see upwards of half
declining so let's say that was
$80,000 if we were to lose $80,000 of
our admissions
revenue for us that's
1.5-2 full-time equivalents we would be
forced to to reconfigure Staffing we
would have to reschedule and
redistribute probably to absorb absorb
that
uh that
loss should New Hampshire parks double
the
fee um and lose less than 50% of the
visitation as has been discussed they
make more money there's no question
about that SEO Science Center as a
partner within the park loses money for
every out ofate visitor that doesn't
come there is no model here where we can
claw back uh any of those
revenues
disincentivized we are about customer
service that's how we have been
successful we provide a highquality
education product we provide a high
quality experience within the park
interpreting the park um and the way we
treat our visitors is of Paramount
important to us one of the impediments
that we address dayto day because we're
the people on the ground is a profoundly
complicated fee Matrix and I've I've got
an example of it here but it's
it's Science Center fees it's it's Parks
fees Library fees participants in
science center programs New Hampshire
school groups in season New Hampshire
school groups out of season out of state
school groups with a facilitated program
without a facilitated Program Center
volunteers participations from the
University of New Hampshire and it kind
of goes on and on and on and what this
creates from a customer service point of
view yes there's clear and clean answers
for all of that as you addressed me at
the at the uh at the admissions
counter but it's a big story to tell and
it's often not easy to tell when we have
a line of visitors trying to get into
into the facility so complications in
that area present logistical challenges
for for us that impede our uh ability to
provide exemplary customer service which
is something we're very proud of we now
use an online ticketing pre-reservation
Service as well it's it's strangely one
of the Silver Linings of Co brought us
to a place where we did that timed
ticketing timed entry better
coordination with parks and collecting
dayuse fees at present we collect dayuse
fees for New Hampshire parks for
visitors who would normally never pay
them as they would come in during the
offseason at parks if someone comes to
visit us in November when there's nobody
no Park staff available they'll register
online they'll pay their fees for the
science center we also charge them the
state park dayuse fee we collect that
hold it in a liability account and
redistribute that back to Parks I think
in 2023 that was about $52,000 from odor
that we collected on Park's behalf and
passed passed back
through I guess in summary I'm I'm
concerned about the impact certainly the
financial impact of the science center
with loss of that Revenue I'm I'm
concerned that it will erode that
visitor
experience and to give you a sense of
the resource that we have operating
within the park part of my job is to
toot our own horn I suppose so forgive
me for a second the quality of the
visitor experience in February USA Today
released a national survey they surveyed
170 aquarium like institutions Across
America and they looked at the visitor
response the the the the the Yelp
reviews the Google reviews the customer
service reviews from all of those
organizations and they assess the
highest quality visitor experience and
beauty of the
aquarium
Fifth Fifth in the nation out of 170
because the experience that our staff is
able to provide and is very focused on
and the spectacular location that we're
afforded within oror Point State Park
those combined for a a profound draw and
and
benefit um
I think that SEO Science Center and odor
Point State Park and New Hampshire parks
is really a stellar example of a public
private partnership within New
Hampshire and I honestly think it should
something that should be celebrated and
cultivated rather than impeded by what I
think
is perhaps unintentionally from our
perspective short-sided
legislation um I ask that you give this
this perspective that I've shared uh
serious consideration as you work
through the disposition of this of this
bill I thank you for your time and
attention I'm happy to answer questions
and I and I have also provided contact
information for me on the back of that
sheet should somebody want to follow up
on any other matters related to the
Science Center thanks for your time any
questions by members of the committee
representative Ron thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question and maybe Mr Wilson can help
out with this but of the people can go
go to odor State Park and not go to the
Science Center how many of
those what what are the numbers look
like like like what percentage of people
that go to odor State part do not go to
the Science
Center we are actually aggregating and
working through those data now it hasn't
been for the last two years since we
both went to online ticketing that we
could even begin to wrestle with it the
preliminary work is
that Science Center is the primary d for
a lot of the visitation um is it 80% no
is it 50 to
70% sometimes of the Year absolutely so
I won't say we are the sole most
significant it's a big piece of the PT
and we'll have those data in the coming
months as we finish working through them
because frankly we want to desperately
you more questions seeing none
thank you very
much that's it for the uh Pink cards
there no one else wish to uh speak on
this
bill I will close
345 oh yes like the blue sheets you can
put the
uh yeah could you send up the blue
sheets with the on that and on the
previous
thank
you and for the for the record one
actually was uh Senator avard signed in
on
301 and was on
345 there were 1 two three four five six
against I'll open the uh hearing
387 Senator Waters floor is yours thank
you Mr chairman I'm uh and members of
the committee I'm Senator David Waters
District 4 to introduce Senate Bill
387 relative to State Parks uh pass
pilot program for Recovery centers and
Community Mental Health Centers um as
you see from the bill what it proposes
to do is as a pilot program which would
provide um as we do in the State Library
uh program a uh pass for use by
participants in a state registered
Recovery Center or Community Mental
Health Center um we have about 30 of
those around the state uh and these are
ones that uh would be able to have the
folks using their services have the
benefits to both recovery and mental
health by being able to be out outside
um we also have since it's a pilot
program a mechanism here for an
anonymized collection of data to see how
the program is going who's using it um
what kind of results again anonymize
that we can be given from the recovery
center and the community M uh health
health centers as to the uh impacts of
the of the program
program um I will just uh say briefly um
that we heard a lot of testimony in the
senate about the all the extensive
research about the benefits of outdoor
recreational experiences uh for people
with mental health uh issues and the
case all the work that I do with the
recovery centers uh the case I believe
is is the same and so there is extensive
research on on that and uh really quite
extraordinary uh benefits that are seen
from it I come also as a member of the
governor's uh Commission on alcohol and
uh other other drugs and uh we have
discussed this program on that
commission and uh Patrick tus who is the
chair of the commission uh has said that
I can express his intent should this
bill passes to use some of our grant
funding for the
$3,000 that will cover the costs so that
while the Parks generously said they
might on the pilot program be able to
provide this I think what we've heard
about the uh budgeting and the financing
of the dependence on the park through
admissions that I would like to be able
to support this with grant funding and I
can assure you that we'll be able to
find those $3,000 uh to support this
pilot program so it's about $105 a pass
um for each each Center and uh they can
give it out to somebody to go go use it
on a on for for the day and um then they
come back and return the pass and uh so
that's that's how it would work for
these these centers
um I think I just would like to say on a
personal note that some of us may have
recognized the importance of being able
to get out outside out to the parks
during Co epidemic when I think we were
all under a lot of mental mental health
stress during that period And I think
that that is a testimony that we have
certainly across the state and uh given
the res search that this can really
particularly help uh people who are
served the 60,000 people are served by
our community mental health centers and
the untold thousands who are uh in in
recovery and served by our um again our
our state registered um recovery centers
that this would be a a good thing we'll
be able to get some data see how how it
works so I hope that they'll have your
support and I we'll be glad to take any
questions any questions of the senator
repr represent ative Darby thank you Mr
chair thank you senator for taking my
question um just a um lack of
understanding on my part so the bill
talks about recovery centers and
Community Mental Health Centers at the
beginning can you describe the
difference between the
two uh oh yes I mean it's it's in their
mission uh Community Mental Health
Centers uh deal with all kinds of um uh
folks many of whom are um on Medicaid or
Social Security Disability or
supplemental security
uh in insurance and um it's really a
this these programs are a safety net for
mental healthiness or emotional
disorders so across all kinds of
conditions recovery centers again these
are the ones that are registered with
the state as eligible for State funding
there's a lot of supervision there's a
there's a a lot of data there's a lot of
rules that are followed these are the
people who are help the the recovery
centers are helping folks who are in
recovery these are registered with
Health Human Services so that they Pro
programs are approved and the funding
that comes through the governor's
commission and from other uh sources um
is supervised by that so that that's why
it's this is very much delimited to
places that the state has confidence in
our serving or clients well and if they
would manage a program like this
appropriately followup for a followup
thank thank you Mr chair um on line nine
um you talked about the anonymized DAT
data collection yeah on line nine it
says participating Community Mental
Health Center shall report this but it
doesn't talk about the recovery centers
is the intent that they would both
I the um Community Health Center I I
think there's a a possibility and
methodology for that I wouldn't say that
it'll become a proxy for the recovery
centers but this will not I was nervous
about putting a a a reporting burden on
the recovery centers I think you know
certainly we can ask them how it's going
and so and so forth but with hipper
provisions and otherwise this was one
that could could work um through with
the Hipp of restraints on providing
information about in individuals about
their health care um so I I that that's
why I differentiated that way and so I
hope that I hope that thank the question
because I hope that will be satisfactory
but I I I think that it this is kind of
reflects the state of what we think we
can
do representative Morgan for question
thank you Mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question uh if I heard you
correctly there's 30 facilities that
would uh require a pass and is it a pass
for the facility or a number of passes
for a number of individuals or group
passes how does that pass situation work
for each facility what would the
associated fee be thanks for your
question I think we we'll hear it is
kind of like the state park um Library
Pass Program which the libraries pay for
as well and uh so um it is in the
possession of the center if somebody
wants to use it it's an individual who
can then take the pass and present it at
a an eligible State Park so that that's
the that's the limitation to it it's not
groups um it's one individual and that
is the
the N the uh about the the 20 recovery
centers and the 10 Community Mental
Health
Centers for
followup thank you the I just want to
understand is there one pass issued for
each facility or is there a number of
passes that they can give to one
individual at a time thanks because one
per facilities okay yeah thank you
sir representative R for question thank
you Mr chair thank you senator for
taking my question so when I see this as
a pilot I see it that's a test and um
who who will report the results or or
who to whom will the reports be the
results be reported to and what would
the criteria be to assess the success of
it and and how would you define the what
it you know um thank you for your
question and
[Music]
um I think maybe you might want to add
something on 12 an amendment okay um
that would suggest to whom that should
go I uh I mean obviously it's going to
be an
HHS okay um but what uh I I had imagined
that this would go to the Commissioners
the commissioner Department of Natural
culture resources and to the uh
Commissioner of Health Human Services I
mean that's that's who I imagined it but
you know it might be useful for this
committee and for Senate HHS to receive
that report as well so whatever you
think is best on that okay my my in
putting together I just assume the
reporting would be going to the uh two
Commissioners because then we could ask
them how to go in two years and decide
what we want to do at that point but if
you think it would be good for us
legislators to have a report too fine
yeah I follow up yeah and um but the
reporting especially since it's going
going to two different Commissioners or
that that's what an amendment would
reflect how is the are each Center going
to have their own is it going to be a
standardized reporting form I'm just
looking at those Commissioners are going
to get are going to receive the report
they'll be assessing whether the pilot
was successful or not but the criteria
that they'll make that determination
would be based on a report that should
be standardized so who should be
preparing should they be preparing the
pilot um evaluation
form thanks for the question
um I think because the pilot I just
tried to keep it real simple because it
we're going to be the ones who decide
whether it's Su success or not right
it's a pilot program if we want to keep
it going in statute which we'd have to
do we'll be the ones who would would
decide so um that's why I thought it it
would it could be a fairly simple
written report um that would include
what they thought was relevant for us to
know but again if you think that it
would be important to have that more
more detailed and specified I you know
the wisdom of this committee is is
nearly infinite Mr chairman nearly
nearly yes yeah how many thank you how
many angels can dance on the head of a
pin any other questions for members of
the committee seeing none thank you Mr
chman
next person Brian
resources good morning again committee
members I'm Brian Wilson director of
division of Parks and Recreation um I
sorry um I will spare uh reading my
testimony into the record here uh some
of it uh resembles uh some of some of
the language in the last just with
regard to explaining our self-funded
model here um we're we we support this
this pilot um and appreciate the
Senator's uh willingness to reach out to
the department to discuss the
particulars around that so that we
thought that we could uh coales around
um a a a good program um so we
appreciate that and um we we do also
recognize the value of uh outdoor
recreation on on folks both mental and
physical health here and uh would would
support uh this as as a pilot um
relative to some of the conversation
regarding re reporting um we uh also at
the department hadn't thought uh a whole
lot about that but we would have um
mechanisms to be able to provide uh data
uh relative to the free frequency or the
the number of visitations either uh
unique to each uh Center um or or or or
more broadly um so I feel like that is
something that um between uh HHS and
dncr that we could work out uh the
particulars of that um but I I would um
uh be supportive of any you know other
amended language as well too that
required any you know uh official
reporting out whether it's to this
committee or or otherwise um that is
also something that similarly happens
with other
uh Pilots or some other uh programs that
purview any any other questions by
members of the
committee representative Derby thank you
Mr chair um thank you for taking my
question just um related to an earlier
question to the senator um what's your
perspective on how um this this these
passes would be used by the by the
centers yeah so uh my understanding is
it's probably it's the closest
resemblance to our library Pass Program
in that there would be a one physical
pass available uh uh at each Center some
level of uh promotion or awareness at
those centers that these exist uh and uh
to um for those that want to take the
opportunity to do that and that it would
be unique um uh so the way that it works
with the library passes uh for instance
is if somebody shows up at a at a state
State Park um where we're charging we're
charging a fee um through our point of
Sal system we're able to enter uh a
unique uh ID number U that's uh
connected to that pass so that we can
produce re reporting uh for that and and
track where where you know where they
where they came from um we don't really
do a whole lot of analysis on the
library program uh for instance it's
been something that's been set within uh
the fee structure for for a long time
and and is a great program
uh but I would see this being being
well representative har question thank
you and thank you for taking my
question um it struck me why can't the
$105
um the passes uh uh a a pass for $105 is
in our current fee package it's either
uh unique to an individual ual
purchasing a season pass um or in the
instance of the libraries it would be
you know unique to a physical place um
or or or Center so um you would not be
able to do that every individual at
that's um participating or a a client at
a Recovery Center would need to get
their own season pass if if it were to
fall under our current uh fee package
for our
followup thank you for a followup so
could you administratively go in and
amend your administrative rules or regs
to have a line item that says centers
can get the pass without having a bill
to tell you to do that yes we could um
go to uh the fiscal committee to uh make
a a change to our fee package to allow
for a program that mirrors uh this
legislation thank
you anyone else other questions seeing
none very
Nam
person chairman and committee members
MERS I don't get to come to this
committee very often so it's nice to be
able to visit and see you all um my name
is Holly Stevens I'm the director of
public policy at Nami New Hampshire
that's the National Alliance on Mental
Illness um Nami New Hampshire is a
nonprofit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide through support advocacy and
education and on behalf of Nami New
Hampshire I'm here today to speak in
favor of Senate Bill 387 7 relative to
the state park passes for the uh
Community Mental Health Centers and
recovery
centers one in five adults and one in
six youth age 6 to 17 experience a
mental illness each year in New
Hampshire this equates to
221,000 individuals in the granite state
who are directly impacted by mental
health condition with 57,000 adults
living with a serious mental
illness in 2021 nearly 40% of adults in
New Hampshire reported symptoms of
anxiety or
depression and of those experiencing a
mental illness 70,000 adults in our
state did not receive any
treatment um as you've heard the
research overwhelmingly shows that
outdoor recreational activities have a
positive impact on Mental Health um this
does include older adults with serious
mental illness as well as folks
experiencing symptoms of anxiety and
depression uh stud have found that
nature-based interventions including
Forest therapies with an emphasis on
immersion in nature had a significant
effect on the reduction of anxiety and
depression um as you've heard there's 10
Community Mental Health Centers um one
of them is here today to speak um which
is wonderful to be able to hear from
them as well um and as you've heard in
2022 they served over 60,000 Unique
Individuals in our state um they do
serve as a primary safety
net
and in 2022 70% of the clientele that
they served are on Medicaid which means
um most of these folks as you've heard
are on Social Security Disability or
supplemental security income and they do
not have the funds to be able to
purchase um daily passes or a season
park pass for themselves um because they
have very little money left over at the
end of the month after paying for their
rent their food their you know for
transportation um and everything else
that we all have to pay for um so
knowing that knowing how many people
receive Services through the Community
Mental Health Centers and knowing that
it's posit would have a positive impact
for them and also knowing these are
folks that can't afford to buy their own
passes um this would be a really great
pilot program um going forward and I
just wanted to um speak to
representative har question about
changing the rules and I think that
because this is a pilot I think letting
it go as a pilot to see how it works and
see you know if folks are actually using
the passes would be a good way to then
you know
direct um the the department to change
rules if it is a successful program but
I think that having this go forward as
it is right now would be um really
important for the folks that are served
by the Community Mental Health Centers
um um so I urge you to seriously
consider this legislation and vote ought
to
pass any questions for members of the
committee
representative thank you Mr chair and
thank you Holly for taking my question
um I'm kind of thinking about that
reporting when the Pilot's over and
reporting to the commissioner of DHHS
and um the parks and what success looks
like but in your testimony you've said
that there's clear research that always
shows the Ben the mental health benefit
of having um people partake in the
natural environment so would you
recommend then that that report that
gets submitted at the end of the pilot
focus more on
usage things like that like since we've
already because I was thinking the
report would maybe include information
about um the Improvement of someone's
mental health in participating in the
pilot but if if if we can already
establish that as as a certainty would
you how how would you look to have that
um report filed like what criteria would
you recommend be included in it and when
you asked that question before I started
thinking about you know what would
success look like and I think success
would look like are people using the
passes um and I think that that's the
most crucial part of the reporting not
what their diagnosis is not you know did
their mental health improve but you know
just where people actually using the
passes would would dictate I think
not representative Horan for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh are your 10
facilities included in the 30 facilities
that were originally mentioned and um by
the senator yeah just for for
clarification my I don't have 10
facilities not mean New Hampshire is a
Grassroots organization we're speaking
in favor of the 10 Mental Health Centers
having these um but we're not directly
affiliated with them just for
clarification but yes those 10 mental
health centers are included in the 30
thank you very
much being no more questions no more
hands thank you very much thank you uh
Martha
Pearson Community Mental Health river
river river Ben good morning everyone
and thank you for hearing my
testimony um I'm here as a Riverbend
employee um and Riverbend is one of the
10 Community Mental Health Centers and I
am definitely in favor of this bill
regarding the state um park passes for
mental health centers um as PE you've
already heard Riverbend is one of 10
Community Mental Health Centers in
conquer serving over
60,000 um clients throughout the state
um and Riverbend itself serves about 30
communities in central New Hampshire so
we're in the sort of conquered marrat
County area um our clients include both
adults and children and um generally
people that have a very serious mental
health conditions and that affect their
daily functioning and very limited
resources um thus limiting their ability
to access things that cost money such as
the state parks
um during my many years at Riverbend
I've actually had a lot of firsthand
experience of how beneficial the
outdoors is for our clients um I've had
a couple of outdoor adventure groups and
we currently have um a Stress Management
and social skills group that regularly
meets Outdoors during the summer months
and um clients often ask about going to
the state parks um specifically because
they like to go swimming and there
aren't a lot of places with lifeguards
um you know where they have good
swimming spots so we've had a lot of
request for the state parks and usually
we have to say it's too expensive um
people don't have the the money to come
up with themselves and Riverbend on
occasion has um we've taken from our own
funds from Riverbend to fund a special
group to a state park so we have been
able to occasionally over the years
utilize some of the state parks for some
special activities but um this bill
would I feel be very beneficial to
people um whether it's you know
individually or as a a group um I think
it would be there would be a lot of um
demand for it and certainly a lot of
benefit
um yeah I think that's pretty much all I
have I I'm an outdoor Enthusiast myself
and I love being outdoors with the
clients that we serve and I've I think
it's one of the greatest Services we can
offer people um especially with our
beautiful surroundings here in New
Hampshire so any questions by any
members of the committee representative
L
montin thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question do you think some
of your clients would have
transportation difficulty getting to the
state park and what do you think would
be solutions for that one thing just as
I'm listening to T Tony a little bit too
I think many of our clients also would
not be able to necessarily access the
part by themselves a lot of the services
we provide now where a staff person is
one-on-one with a client or in some of
the cases we've had small groups of
clients with the staff or two um so this
in that case the staff provide the
transportation um you know and I don't
know if this bill would include the pass
for the assist the sort of the staff
person who would be providing support
for the client to be able to access the
state park um I think in the past when
we have utilized a I think it's called
the state park bus pass program which
unfortunately is only for children um it
was set up like that there would be a I
think it was a 10: one ratio um but
there would be a sort of like a bus pass
so the the transportation in the bus or
the van would include the 10 clients and
the one or two staff um and everyone's
entrance would be covered um so it the
logistics of individuals using it um
could be a little complicated in some
cases
yes any more questions being
none thank you very much thank you and
that's the end of the morning
session if there's L there's someone
else who wishes to speak I don't see
anybody close the
hearing it'll we we'll uh be back at 1
o'
back
e
hey are we ready ready are you ready hey
you know we just they're just going to
for
okay2
okay I know no there's no windows oh you
have those you actually yeah but they
have the 76 in here is
window
well I don't know this is going to be
very
quick right now I only have I only have
one card only one
card
so all
right okay folks let's why don't we go
we only we said 1:00 and it's a couple
minutes after
so
yours good
afternoon Mr chairman and honor
honorable me members of the energy and
natural resources committee for the
record my name is Carrie gendro District
1 Senator thank you for letting me
propose a couple of minor changes to RSA
227 C colon 122 which is relative to
prohibiting metal detecting in certain
areas metal detecting has been on the
increase and and when it comes to um
some exciting discoveries but also it
has some challenges and I think this
increase has been because of like Oak
Island and other people and I think even
during covid people were wanting to get
outside um but among the list of current
places that one can metal detect are
athletic fields and school grounds and
one of my constituents um from district
one had called me and said that on the
athletic fields uh metal detectors are
digging up they're finding things but
they're digging them up but they're not
filling in the rivens so he had propo or
asked me to um submit this um not to
exclude metal detecting but just to
prohibit it from the uh uh athletic
fields and also school grounds the
results um have been in needless
injuries so I'm proposing that we take
athletic fields and school grounds off
the list of places one can metal detect
I would also propose that we change the
name dumps that's an old word we used to
use dumps to the name uh transfer
station thank
you any questions
but repres
representative representative Rong poor
question I know you've you've beaten
Dar several times already and that's
amazing you've been practic you've been
practicing no I I had my hand up I want
to speak to the next bill Mr chair just
that um go right thank you very much Mr
chair and thank you senator for taking
my question I actually have two one is
um what if someone's um there's a soccer
player and let's say a treasured
necklace fell off well during a game and
would it prohibit her or friends from
going out to try to find it on the
soccer field that would not prohibit
that this is these are folks that are
deliberately going out to to dig up um
treasure that hasn't been found yet so
in a case like that I think what you'd
find is there'd be a a group of people
just going out and looking probably a
necklace that was lost during a soccer
game would be more on Surface anyway
oh CU see these people and then is
treasure hunting defined in in that area
of Statute that it's a recreational
activity that it's not really purposeful
to I well I think a lot of people do it
for a living too I know um on the Sea
Coast a lot of folks will do it for fun
but also there's this one gentleman I
can't think of his name now I was being
told this morning who he was and he
actually goes out to some of the beaches
and digs up and he has a website for
lost Rings oh wow so so it is I mean
there there's a lot to it and a lot of
people do it we own some um acreage up
in district one and my brother is a huge
metal detector um guy and we have some
Old Farm sites and seller holes and
he'll go around and and dig but there's
no danger to anybody like on an athletic
field okay and I was um just wondering
if it would improve the bill if instead
of Del leading athletic fields or school
grounds if it's said or otherwise
prohibited so that it would leave it up
to the local control local
municipalities to decide okay we're
going to not allow it on this school
ground or this park because it may even
be you know city parks or town Parks
people may be doing it and so I'm just
wondering if if what you would think
about that well well if you read the
bill it says on following lands own and
control by the state its agencies
departments commissions and institutions
unless a historic resources and such
land has been recorded and restricted as
posted I think the way you have it is
for just for just on state land correct
state or state or or public land
correct yeah yeah yeah so it's defined
but it's a good good question it really
is a good question leaving it up because
we don't want government overreach so
leaving it up to the m mun
alties okay all right thank you yeah
you're welcome thank you for the
question any other question that
second slow
Derby thank you senator for taking my
question this is actually exactly
related to what the chair just mentioned
the the um the text of existing statue
um says uh following lands owned or
controlled by the state but the athletic
fields that you're referring to what is
an example of an athletic field that's
state
PSU good example
PSU so that's an athletic field um any
type of college campus that has an
athletic field or even state funded I'm
trying to think even a in a locally
owned municipality where the state would
own it I can't think of anything right
now but yeah nhti good
well yeah good good question I mean
actually this as it's written uh I guess
this is the actual law and you're just
putting a couple of strike throws and
changes this is just the law that that
says what you can do on public on state
land not
uh I guess the individual towns I would
assum can do it on what can just do it
on their own
property
representative thank you Mr
chairman thank you senator for taking my
question um it's a would you believe
would you believe that there's a series
of definitions in
227c that defines things like historic
property historic resources Etc and I
think it's applicable to
this it probably answers that some of
the other represent have questions thank
you representative wolf a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um school
grounds that's a pretty
broad area I mean I'm thinking of kage
which has 60 Acres out there and people
would want to go out
and treasure hunt so by I I like what
whether it was Senator uh representative
Derby or representative run said unless
otherwise prohibited so the school
district could prohibited on their
grounds would you be acceptable to an
amendment like
that okay I'm okay with that
it's if you want to bring it in um it
well let's let's go through the
testimony and and the questioning I
think the biggest thing that this
constituent was concerned about was and
it was specific to the colbrook athletic
field and what he found was that the um
the participants the those that were on
the athletic field whether it's soccer
field hockey whatever there were
injuries you know I would love to say
that those are out those that are out
metal detecting that they would do due
diligence and cover up the where they've
dug but they hadn't been doing that so
it has caused injury so that's how this
all come about so that we want to be due
diligent in um in preventing
injury
well representative G and representative
I just wonder why a place can't put up a
sign that says that they prohibit it
like we say no hunting on our property
why can't people just do that on their
own it's a good question um that would
be good if everyone read the signs and
Then followed them I agree with you it
would be good I think in this case where
at school grounds they um probably feel
like the public as a tax paay have the
right to that property as well they and
they do they could go picnic they could
do whatever but the injuries that occur
because of digging up um this through
metal detecting um has been
problematic thank
you representative
Hoy thank you
um
you mentioned colbrook I was an NCA
referee for several decades and I did a
lot of games up in C Brook and I don't
think it was the treasure Hunters the
field was just freaking
horrible simple as that unless they were
know comment any other questions members
of the committee uh well I just have
something to say somebody who
has done this for
recreationally there is some certain
Unwritten rules and
sometimes we live in a society right now
that people don't give a rats about
anything and about it's all about me
well they don't some people just are
plain old-fashioned rout and sometimes
you have to put something in law just to
try to put uh put some put some on it I
wish there was something I don't know
maybe there hopefully there is uh that
uh in some other part of this of the uh
of the of the statute that speaks about
some kind of punishment for that because
for those of us who do it we we use our
heads and we Pat it down because we know
we're on somebody else's property right
so right but I I think what the way this
read
this is this is where where people can
go now and we're just scratching out
certain things on state land they cannot
do they can still do it on beaches they
can do it on perimeters of SE of
cemeteries unpaved roads but this is
says no you can't go there now and it's
unfortunate but that's sometimes you got
to say okay we got to just say no you
can't do it so yeah
I I agree with what's in the
bill representative Rome so I have a
little confusion because it does say
Exempted so treasure hunting with metal
detectors and dowsing rods is Exempted
from the restrictions of the subdivision
on the following lands owned or
controlled by the state so senator in in
with your constituents concerned that's
not state-owned land is it it's local
it's a it's a mun School District own
land School District correct so this
wouldn't help that problem because this
only applies to state land you know like
a school grounds or athletic fields that
are owned by the state so we'd have to
put in something that encompasses
municipality if you want it to yeah I
don't know if
this I don't know have not looked at the
uh at the rest of the the the law I mean
you're looking at it right now uh
representative M uh is there anything in
it for other than the state or is this
only on state property is that that
section of that law I may you may it may
be too so too big to read everything
through it is there anything on in other
sections so as so as I read it m Mr Mr
chairman there's a large section of
definitions under 227
C1 uh that defin commissioner council
department historic preservation
historic property historic
resource uh the historic property is
anything that's been listed in the
historic register of uh register of
historic
places uh any object or group of objects
associated with historic properties etc
etc
and so for us to do anything beyond the
scope here would require
additional
research I mean Tre treasure hunting
isn't further
defined to representative rang's point
I'm not my opinion is I'm not sure needs
to be defined I mean it talks about the
the current statute talks about treasure
hunting with metal detectors and dowsing
rods I'm not sure how we'd further
Define
it we
could
um there's another question while you're
while you're looking for anything else
uh representative Derby thank you Mr
chair this just to your point entire the
entire 227c talks about state land and
state controlled resources I think that
you're correct that if we wanted to do
provide the ability presuming it's not
already there for municipalities to set
these regulations that would have to go
in a different part of
Statute so okay thank you yeah
so so we would so so so to meet the
thing meet the issue around local
schools that would have to be some other
but if I don't know uh where where do we
want to go from here I mean I I just
assumed past this right now but but
unfortunately I'm missing my my uh
ranking well let's take uh why don't we
well let's we still got a few minutes uh
if we can uh wait for anyone else to
show up but I don't know if uh anyone is
going to show up uh representative
representative
I just have one other comment thank you
Mr chair I do I'm slightly concerned
about the lack of definition of treasure
hunting esec especially with respect to
representative Run's question about
somebody that may have lost jewelry and
be searching for the jewelry and I think
the treasure hunting needs to be um
needs to be a bit more carefully defined
but otherwise I think that the bill
makes sense especially because of um as
people pointed out to me um you know the
state-owned athletic fields that we
yeah Mr chair I'd be happy to work on an
amendment that defines treasure hunting
and metal detecting because I see
treasure hunting is the disturbance of
the
surface and I think that's the big
problem here is the disturbing this
because I could look at this treasure
hunting and it could be the example of a
young athlete that lost a a NE neace cuz
that's a treasure you're hunting for it
um but that's not what the senator is
talking about she's talking about
disturbing the surface and creating
damage and I think that behavior needs
to have a different definition than
something I mean it's just a matter of
putting in here you don't have to
necessarily even Define treasure hunting
but just say something like is if you're
digging below the
surface right disturbing disturbance
yeah surface disturbance yeah there you
in but it's still I mean just so we know
that it this is still not solving
Senator constituents problem because
that's not state owned land right that
would probably if it
exists if probably ex exists in other
other statutes where somebody is
basically
trespassing and doing and actually
damaging the the property right that's a
that's that's that's a m that's a
criminal mischief if nothing else the
school defines the rules they prohibit
dogs for instance so yeah I mean there
be uh more point of clarification too
if with Senator Harvey Bully's
suggestion which I think is excellent we
would want that to apply to everything
so if they are disturbing the surface of
the beach they should repair that they
should fill that back in with sand or if
they're on an unpaved Road and they're
digging a hole that's still going to
cause a hazard they should fill that
in yeah well let's that we have a nice
easy Bill let's not get it to the point
that somebody's got a lot of work to do
you've got a lot of work to do you know
you just haven't heard for the last
three bills you you've got an idea on
everyone guess
what representative har then
representative thank you senator for
taking this question it's a tradeoff of
Representative rang I think she
mentioned a point of order but I would
like to know your opinion you now know
that this bill as you propos only
relates to State Property you still in
favor of your bills very much so and I
think what I'm I'm probably stretching
it a little bit further but I think even
that taking the school in colbrook if
they're receiving State funds um with
that and it's probably a stretch but
would that still be considered um State
Property no
okay thank you you're
welcome representative wolf thank you
thank you for taking my question I think
there's so
many unanswered questions in here as to
you know digging up the the beach and
things like that I think the bill almost
ought to start all over again with a
complete
cleanup I hate to say that to you
Senator but we're dancing around the
horn here and I think if you want a full
amendment that may be the way to go simp
folks maybe it's me but somebody drove
in to get a g gallon of gas and now you
want to rebuild the
car I me
No I gave them the gallon of gas and a
can and sent them on their way yeah but
she haven't we haven't done the bill
yet I mean you want to
change you want you want to or what do
you want to
do do you w to I I think I think the
bill is going to be so amended that we
ought to start with a whole new bill or
make one amendment that change ches
everything down through there well
there's no what do you need is an
amendment other than a change in maybe
in what treasure hunting is well I I
first of all there's two points here one
is to we we see that there's some
shortcomings with the bill lack of
definition of treasure hunting you know
damage to those other things that are
still allowed it still doesn't solve the
constituent issue so there is a
possibility we could just itl it and
people that have an interest in this
area can bring a new bill back in the
fall I mean I don't I think schools can
can make their own laws about yeah
well where are
going I don't believe
this I mean somebody comes in with a a
five minute Bill and all of a sudden
it's
we have to do the Magna
Carta give me a
break am I in another room Another
Universe good Lord the world upside down
help me out here Mr chairman another
another another
possibility another possibility to take
the opposite view of my friend and
representative rung is we just pass the
bill as suggested then come back next
year with another bill uh what I would
like to know as a lawyer and A
legislature is how long has this bill
been in effect that nobody's brought up
the issue of what is treasure hunting if
we've live with this bill for 50 years
I'm not too concerned to not pass what
the senator would like for a definition
that nobody's questioned for 50 years
and we always have in the law the little
subnote that most people don't read if
it's not defined in the statute go to
Webster's Dictionary it's in there
usually we do that in all the bylaws and
regulations locally because you can't
Define everything so I'll bet dollars to
Donuts I might even buy everybody a cup
of coffee Webster's Dictionary will
Define treasure hunting so I think we're
okay with that I'm not opposed but now
Mr chair we're getting into discussion
sit you haven't spoken for the first
time
re oh thank you Mr chair I feel like
we've gone into an executive session and
I would like
to not do that okay well was this only
brought this up is because we were there
was a possibility of being able to
execute right now but I don't think
that's going to happen and then we're
probably going to have to go to a 101 on
the floor
okay I I just want to U thank you Mr
chair I just wanted to respond to
representative harb's question I did
look at the you know this the Legacy
line on that bill the last time it was
amended was in 2003 and this was not
changed then the previous time was 1985
and we don't have the history so it's
been a long time to your point I agree
you yeah thank you representative Derby
for bringing that up and would would
would you believe that Miriam Webster
defines treasure hunting as an act of
Treasure can we look
amazing yes are we uh all right you want
help any question any more questions we
will not hit exec we will exec it in two
weeks this has been a real
treat yeah how do you think I
welcome
welcome welcome to my world Senator
welcome welcome to my world you only
have you only have you only have four
minutes well said I
was referee for 25 years and when I did
my NFA game I get paid big money so
every time I got a I I always went up in
north New Hampshire because I knew they
had horrible referees up there so I
wanted
to
e
then you won't have to do it again I
won't do it with a metal DET all right
the
go open the hearing on House
Bill
492 relative
to Wastewater
engineering uh representative buffo I
guess
is
Bill thank you Mr
chairman for the record my name is Tom
buo I'm state representative from Carol
County district one including the town
of
Conway um I appear before you here today
as a co-sponsor of Senate Bill
192 the intent of this bill is to remove
one single word from the RSA
486 the word intercepting is not clearly
defined and because of this confusion
the statute is not consistently in
interpreted this misinterpretation is
causing municipalities to have
difficulties uh
estimating what portion of their sewer
infrastructure projects are eligible for
the state aid
grants deleting the word interception
will clarify the definition and the
interpretation of the statute and ensure
that all sewers qualify for the state
aid grants therefore I request that you
this committee recommend this bill ought
to pass thank
you any questions uh for uh
representative
buo okay thank you very much
you
call uh Tracy
Dees good afternoon chairman rulu and
members of the committee my name is
Tracy wood and I am the administrator of
the Wastewater engineering Bureau at
Dees I work under r
Peter Senate Bill
492 uh ask for three things the first
thing is it is asking to the remove the
word the descriptor word intercepting
from sewers for the purposes of applying
for and distributing state aid grants
under RSA
486 why is this
important I've been in I can't believe
this 30 years I've been doing this and
back in the day um as a young engineer
we used to try to Define all the
different types of sewers we would have
trunk sewers we'd have intercepting
sewers we would have collector sewers
and they all try to have a specific
meaning the problem is is in
application because every Community is a
different size so in one Community what
you want to call like the main trunk
sewer may look a little bit different in
a smaller Community like what does it
mean in Manchester versus what does it
mean in Woodsville right so having that
in people's minds swirling around like
how what does this intercepting really
mean and so by removing the word
intercepting we're just saying all
public sewers are eligible for state aid
grant and that's the intent and that's
also how we apply in our clean water srf
program is that all public sewers are
eligible for srf funds whereas private
sewers are not so this brings
consistency it alleviates that
um you know what the trying to figure
out what intercepting means and for
communities that have to plan their
project and they're working out their
funding package and what that'll look
like and they may be State a grant may
be a part of that they're going to want
to know what part of their project is
eligible for state aid grant and what
isn't so removing this word will be very
helpful it's a simple change but a very
important
change the next item this bill um does
is it raises the fee for wastewater
operator
certificates and the fee has been $50
since
1996 we have actually had a request from
the regulated Community they're willing
to increase the fee they want to
increase the fee New Hampshire Water
Pollution Control Association is
supposed to be submitting a letter of
support for this and
what this fee is used for well in the
RSA where we have this training center
in Franklin New Hampshire it's located
at the same location as our regional
wastewater treatment facility the
wbp and this is where we do all the
training for the certified Wastewater
operators in the state of New Hampshire
so these monies that are collected are
supposed to go into this non-lps account
and they're supposed to pay
for a lot of things the upkeep of the
train in Center
um and basically giving back to the
operators so right now we collect
$155,000 a year on average we have about
600 certified operators in the state and
they pay $50 to become a new operator to
renew to seek
reciprocity and so this would be a
doubling of that fee at their request
they're looking for this and what
they're looking for us is to offer we're
in the Dark Ages I have to admit it if
you go to the training center we still
have an overhead projector you know
we're trying to install new technology
to keep up with the times we're asking
our operators to operate these
multi-million doll facilities and we're
using an overhead projector you know
they're demanding more from us and so
this increas in fees would be we'd
utilize that to give back to the
regulated Community um for instance
sometimes will buy a piece of equipment
like a flow meter that can be used at
from community community they may just
need it for a short period of time and
they may not want to invest in that
piece of equipment and so we'll purchase
it and then we will loan it out to the
different communities to use so that's
how we use those fees
um we just had to replace the cat 6
cable at the training center for $10,000
don't ask me what it is but it's a cable
that's required
um and we had to update it so we're
seeing increasing costs the training
center needs to be updated and we want
to respond to our certified operators
another thing I can mention is that
every for Renewal they have to have 20
continuing education units and so that's
why we're providing this training is for
them to get that and they're also asking
that we move from paper tests to online
testing and all of these things cost
money and want to give it to them but we
that the third thing this bill does is
it's another simple change um it
changes the the term Consulting
Engineers or the phrase Consulting
Engineers to Consulting engineering
firms so one of the things that we we do
per oursa 485 a A3
a I'd have to look it's 485a though in
that statute we're required to um create
a list of pre-qualified engineering
firms for in the state of New Hampshire
and so basically any licensed
engineering firm who wants to be on the
list um submits an application they get
on the list right now we have 51 firms
on that list it's a longstanding list um
we're about to update we're in the
process of updating the rules e and
vc500 um and in
that we actually had two categories we
had you could be an individual applicant
which didn't even make sense I don't I
don't know why any why that was even in
there we're not in the business of
creating a list of
individual licensed engineers in the
state I'm a PE in the
state I am certified through the New
Hampshire
oplc why would New Hampshire Dees keep a
list of IND individual firms it just
didn't make sense so anyways we're
moving away we're taking that out we
don't have anyone on the list that was
an an individual because the purpose of
that list is we have four categories and
the purpose is for municipalities to be
able to go to that list and say oh okay
what what engineering firms in the state
are qualified to do major Wastewater
infrastructure work or major water
distribution work and so communities can
use that list to hire firms that we have
pre-qualified so REM so basically
changing Consulting Engineers to
Consulting to Consulting engineering
firms just solidifies that we're not
there to create a list of Consulting
Engineers like I could be a Consulting
engineer as an individual we're there to
create a list of Consulting engineering
firms so that concludes my testimony if
answer representative
heart them all
out I want to Star for this Mr chair uh
thank you for taking my question as a
sole practitioner I'm concerned about
taking out Consulting Engineers because
I wouldn't have a firm if I'm
pre-qualified and I meet your
qualifications for this I can see people
looking at your website to perhaps find
somebody locally that can help them now
I'm going to be cut off your website
because I'm not a firm so why wouldn't
you do both if you want to and and not
throw out the individual engineer what I
can say is you're not on our list right
now we don't have a list of individual
Engineers that's what oplc does so you
can go on to that website and you can
look me up on that that website and you
can find my license number and see that
I'm certified to do work in New
Hampshire this does not mean you can't
do work in New
Hampshire it's a list of pre-qualified
licensed engineering firms
so if you're a firm Are you a
firm I would say if you're a sole
practitioner or engineer you're not a
firm right exactly so you you can do
work in New Hampshire this does not
preclude you from doing work in New
Hampshire this is specifically for
licensed engineering firms who and what
we're trying to do is provide this
listed communities that are doing
multi-million dollar projects that are
looking for firms that have the
capabilities to do that work you know
because my in my Bureau we oversee the
Clean Water srf program so we provide
the funding for the Wastewater infrastru
I should say clean water infrastructure
projects in the state because we do
Wastewater and storm water so this does
not preclude you from doing work in the
state of New
Hampshire it's just you're not on that
particular
list follow followup you may have
answered this but at this time you have
no individual
Consulting thank you at at this thank
you for taking the followup at this time
you have no individual Consulting
Engineers on your list of preapproved
firms or pre-approved people correct we
do not and that's why it's made the the
transition and the rules it's making it
easier because we're not cutting anyone
off that was historically on the list
okay thank
you representative Darby for a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um with respect to the
intercepting term um do I understand
that the the state aid grant already in
um includes all public sewers and so the
correct for a followup thank you Mr
chair for the followup thank you again
um there's a part of this bill which
eliminates the fines and late fee the
late fees um that that you know there's
no compensation for those late fees so
are those something that the department
regularly collects um is there any
concern about delinquent municipalities
uh um paying you know missing those late
fees and is there any enforcement
required in order to make sure that
people the the fees are
paid um so the late fee just going to
pull that
out
is this is for the the cert wastewater
operator
certification it it it this has been an
awkward statement for us and it's
conflicting we've had several
conversations with the lawyers
is like if I'll go by my experience as
an engineer right every two years I have
to renew my PE license and I have to
submit my cus and my fee and I have to
do that by a certain date if I don't do
that by a certain date I no longer have
my license and so that's the same thing
here is like if you're a certified
wastewater operator and you have a
2-year license and it expires on a
certain date and you don't submit your
renewal application in your fee you're
no longer certified so we're trying to
be consistent with what other agency
across the state are doing plus we want
everyone just to submit on time we don't
want to be in the business of collecting
late fees and so we actually have a very
robust program of notifying people hey
your license is going to expire hey did
you forget your license is about to
expire and so we're really working on
fees any other
questions M of the committee being none
you honorable Mr
chello Mr chairman I made a mistake I'm
going to speak on oh 589 I oh I'm sorry
I apologize you know you no um I got the
left
when oh here this one okay oh
this is 492 as well I think he was the
first
patro oh for for the senator okay yeah
yeah uh good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Phil Tetro and I am
Senator Richard's legislative Aid uh and
I'm here to introduce uh SP 492 on
behalf of Senator rardy um Senator rardy
wishes she could be here today to
introduce this important piece of
legislation however she was already
committed to an event in her District um
I'm going to be brief today as I think
uh representative buo and Tracy already
touched on a lot of the main points uh
in my testimony so uh Senate Bill 492
clarifies the following purposes uh of
making consistent RSA 486 uh clearly
defined so that that it can be applied
in a consistent manner uh first the bill
addresses the clarification of the term
intercept Interceptor
sewer uh second uh the bill addresses
the Wastewater operators uh
certification fee and lastly SP 492
addresses clarification for the term uh
Consulting engineer um and if you have
any questions uh for Senator shardy I'm
more than willing to passes on to her
but uh for now I will defer to uh Tracy
representative Buco and Bill behind me
so thank
you any questions by members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
Hansel thank you Mr
chairman uh my name is Bill Hansel it's
been quite a while since I've testified
before you uh I was in your seat for in
84 82
87 uh I'm representing Granite State
Rural Water
Association North Conway water Precinct
and low Bartlett water Precinct two
precincts in Mount Washington
Valley this bill Uh clarifies u a lot of
U what this program is all about uh the
grant state aid grant on funding Water
and Wastewater projects this particular
one has to do with Wastewater
uh House Bill 2 last session uh added uh
Cav caveat that municipalities that
finished their project had one year of
warranty uh that went by
before uh the state would start making
the payments uh in other words the
budget's already there with the money
but it has to go to governor councel for
final approval and it won't go there
until the oneyear warranty during that
one-year warranty house bill to said you
have that year to get your application
in for certification for
payment the certification for payment
can't go in from a municipality until
final completion all this is overseen by
the Department of Environmental Services
so it's critically important now for you
to consider that um the backlog of
getting those applications in is
somewhat confusing by this one word
interceptor so taking that out just
clarifies it and allows municipalities
to not have to go through some much
cumbersome paperwork and also helps us
the dees engineering Bureau do the same
uh so really will expedite that
application process and allow it to fall
in the rhythm of the one-year warranty
period then as soon as the warrant is up
the application of all darn certific it
can go to government Council because
this this program pays uh 20 20 to 30%
of annual principal interest payments on
the municipal bond to build these
Wastewater Plant uh right now there's
about
U uh say it's averaging 25% some some
some get 10 some if you have stress
rates you get an extra 10 which is 30
that that is $15 million here that's
already in the budget so the money is
there for the
program but the money it can't be
distributed until the certification for
payments so the Rhythm the rhythm of it
has to match that and oddly enough the
first Bond payment from the Federal
loans which a lot of them get rural
development loans and grants the the
First Federal Loan payment is done just
about one year after and so the first
payment for the state their portion
would fall into line with that and it
would help uh Leverage that right now
it's 15 million a year leverage it's
leveraging $600 million of already
completed Wastewater infrastructure so
you can see the tremendous uh capacity
it has to make this affordable at the
municipal level so it's very critical to
get this word out of there make it clear
so especially from the municipal point
of view of passing bonds to build these
Wastewater uh projects it it makes it
more understandable for the for the
people people in the municipalities that
are going to vote on those bonds and
makes it very uh reliable that the
programs there to help fund monies in
the budget this will clarify the process
for application so that's a bit of a
detailed
explanation and and from a municipal
point of view we're we're all for
raising the fee for to help oversee the
licensing and the engineering firms are
glad to see the engineering firms
you know certified by the dees if you
look at the statute it says the dees
overseas is is to help the
municipalities and it oversees it every
step of the way they oversee all of the
invoices they oversee the
preconstruction meetings of uh final
completion substantial completion final
completion retainage so that they they
hand carry you through with the with the
engineering firm that the municipality
hires there was quite a team effort and
those M those engineering firms goes
through request or proposal by the
municipality a selected by the
municipality approved by the DS but they
can also team those firms can Team
within any individual Engineers they
want to make the team they present to to
the community to to be selected so it's
it doesn't lock anybody builds a better
team uh there's quite a lot of knowledge
needed to build Wastewater facility more
controls and piping and all that goes
into it so it takes a takes a pretty
good uh combination of Engineers working
together to to get it done so I we
municipalities very much in support
that there any questions by uh members
of the
much
see
I see no other P
cards is there anyone else who wishes to
bill seeing none
no I will close the
hearing
hey uh there this bill has a fee on it
I'm not a and I think I'm going to say
no I would not we still have two uh we
have two weeks to take care of
it so uh I'm not going to ex I I will
not move to execut
now I think I want to it's an election
year
fees that with but then again I'm not
uh we will the next hearing is
at
e
uh thanks Mr chairman Senator David
Waters District 4 and I'm here on behalf
of Senator dallis sander who couldn't uh
couldn't be here today to introduce
Senate Bill 549 relative procedures for
inspection and transfer of dams and
establishing a committee to study
alternatives for funding and and so
forth um this bill comes to you
unanimously through the uh Senate I'll
just give a little background I know we
have uh Corey Clark here from the dam
Bureau to talk a little bit more on
details about the current
situation um we
do nhdes is responsible for
reconstruction Rehabilitation of some
273 state-owned dams and they operate uh
28 of those dams um think of the some of
the big lakes uh winaki winnisquam Squam
Newfound sopy uh
oapi and uh currently um Dees in the
process of evaluating the systemwide
needs of New Hampshire's state-owned
dams and categorizing those dams by
their um purpose and needs and they have
really discovered um how much there are
increasing Capital needs like everything
else the uh increase in in costs and uh
that operational cost these dams is
starting to outpace the funding sources
and the resources that we have um for
them um so that's why the bill comes
forward particularly in the study
committee part of it to look at uh to
evaluate these Financial read needs and
to see if there are potentially other
Revenue sources now historically um this
this effort has been funded by revenue
generated from leasing state owned
hydropower uh dams um but these revenue
streams have decreased um result because
of a lot of factors outside of
Dees uh controls so um what this will do
is give us a mechanism to evaluate the
current funding sources the possibility
of other um funding sources to keep the
dam Bureau financially um liable and
then I think import importantly in this
effort you'll see on the first uh
section of the bill um lines 8 through
uh 11 and then a couple language you
know kind of little tweaks to the
language after that but that first part
um is going to be important in terms of
um clarifying the kinds of uh uh the
kinds of um non- Menace dams and uh how
the dam Bureau can reclassify non--
Manis Dam to a higher classification
based and the amount of water that Dam
can discharge so that's that's why you
see lines 8 to 11 there and that that is
really a kind of a basic inspection and
safety issue part of the part of the
bill um Mr chairman I would be happy to
answer questions but I think you're
going to get correct answers from the
up
[Music]
much thank you uh chairman uh steam
members um I was also notified that uh
Senator Lou wouldn't be here today so I
came in just in case um as you will see
that there is a uh for the record Mark
mcon I represent the good people of uh
Carroll County District dat i chair
Public Works and highways and on the U
odd years our charge is the capital
budget and uh funding for the dam
Authority or the dams comes through
capital budget so I believe that's why
um the Senate was anxious to bring
myself and representative cluder into
this bill uh because we are typically
the ones that have handled this over the
past 20 years my only concern over the
whole bill is is the quick reporting
time which is November 1st of
2024 um and I know in commissions that
we've all been a part of um especially
trying to figure out how to do fund
tolling or roads going forward we found
a need for a longer term uh but I would
leave that to the Senator's request um I
myself uh am in favor of the legislation
you good afternoon chairman members of
the committee I'm Corey Clark chief
engineer at the dam Bureau at the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and um one thing I do want to
mention is that this the language in
this uh s SP 549 is very similar to the
bill that was before you previously HB
1277 um but basically because there was
a dueling Bills going on this committee
uh voted to itl that bill and so that's
why we're looking at sp sp 549
now and so uh just to uh go over some of
the things that uh Senator Waters
previously mentioned State of New
Hampshire we have 273 state-owned dams
we operate roughly 208 of those dams and
given the capital needs of of all those
structures we we looked at last about a
year ago what what would it take to
actually repair all those structures
we're looking at roughly about $414
million the capital needs to repair all
those 2 73 state-owned dams and when we
look at just the 63 High Hazard dams out
of that list we're looking at roughly
about $300 million to re rehabilitate
all those dams and bring them into
current
compliance and so as the senator
mentioned historically the costs for
operation maintenance repair of
state-owned dams were funded by solely
by the dam maintenance fund and the dam
maintenance fund does receive revenue
from hydropower sources we currently
lease about nine dams to hydropower
entities throughout the state and we
take a portion of the revenue generated
at those sites as lease payments back to
the
state what occurred in the early 2000s
is these power purchase agreements that
were set up in the 1980s with
PSNH uh the the hydropower um entities
were receiving roughly about uh 17 cents
per kilowatt hour or thereabouts that
dropped in in the early 2000s when PSS H
renegotiated their above Market power
purchase agreements in accordance to RSA
374f and now they're receiving roughly
about 3. cents 6 cents per kilowatt hour
now there are are other factors that do
come into play some of the renewable
energy credits that some of these sites
are are seeing so um but overall the the
revenue generated by these sites is
decreasing these sites are requiring a
lot more capital investment the same as
what I previously mentioned for the
state owners dams so the the capital
investment needs at these sites are are
are outpacing the um the revenue
generated by these sites and
so because of what happened in the early
2000s uh nhds worked with the
legislature in 2004 under SP 488 to
review the effects of Rec the utility
reconstruct restructuring and at that
time uh a legislative committee was
formed that looked at different ways to
generate Revenue the two big ones that
came out of that were the UN un
unrefined roll toll gas tax to boter and
a shoreline maintenance fee those two
options were um were brought forth in
legislation however both both options
didn't make it through uh one didn't
make it out of committee the other one
was itl so since then we we've still
been relying on increasing capital and
general funding needs to cover the
expenses of the dam Bureau as the dam
maintenance fund continues to to
decrease and so one thing that we'd be
very interested in as part of this
legislation is is a new committee
however one thing we do want to realize
is that we we want to make sure we
actually get tangible results out of
this committee and we don't continue
just doing what we did in 2004 so
certainly uh folks on the committee that
chair of the committee we we really want
to make sure that um they are interested
in actually moving forward some
legislation that can really make a
tangible difference to the dam Bureau
and cut down on the amount of capital
and general fund money that we need to
keep these dams in proper working
order the other thing that this
legislation would do is um is amend RSA
482 goon 12 that would um reclassify
non-- Mena
stams allow I'm sorry allow nhcs to
reclassify non- Menace dams when a
failure of that Dam would impact um
folks Downstream that would actually
require a higher Dam classification what
essentially that is is
currently with non- Mena stams we can't
reclassify them if nothing has changed
Downstream so even though there might be
infrastructure or house if that if that
house or infrastructure has been there
since the dam was originally classified
uh prior to 1981 we can't reclassify
that that Dam it's it's basically kind
of like a grandfathering clause the
issue is becoming is even though nothing
has changed Downstream those impacts of
a dam failure do impact other people
other than the dam owner a great example
of this is up in Newport last last July
actually I'm sorry at the end of June
prior to the big rains in July but we
had some big rains in June a non- menus
Dam failed took out a uh driveway and
did property damage to a downstream of
butter that dam was inspected by the
nhdes in
2019 and those impacts were realized but
because of the current statute we were
unable to reclassify that Dam to try to
bring it up to proper working order so
this this helps clarify some of that the
other thing that would also help clarify
is because of the the revenue sources
that we're looking at we are looking at
potentially selling some of our Hydro
dams uh we are in negotiations right now
currently with a hydro operator to
purchase one of our sites so we want to
just make sure that any Revenue not just
Hydro lease Revenue but any sale revenue
or any other Revenue can be deposited
back into that Dam maintenance fund and
well thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question this kind of a
general question but say you do sell the
dam to a private um company what role
does the state still play in um
inspecting the dam or any other
oversight of the
dam so the the vast majority with a very
few exceptions of hydropower dams are
regulated by the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission so they're
regulated by the fits uh so that would
that would certainly transfer each hydr
power Dam has to have a license through
FK and that license would be continued
to be held by the hydropower
generator uh and so that site from a
regulatory standpoint would still be
regulated in the same manner and fashion
that it is currently today if it was a
nonh hydrop power site so if it was a uh
a dam in which a municipality wanted to
take over or a Lake
Association the St State Dam safety
program would still regulate that Dam
the same way it's currently regulated
we're still subject to all um Dam safety
regulations with all the state owned
dams and so those regulations would
well thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question you said some of
the money from um leasing goes to the
dam fund what happens to the rest of it
oh I'm sorry I I I'm apparently misspoke
it all goes to the damn maintenance fund
you thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Clark for taking my question so if I me
to understand you correctly the um kind
of the shortfall or the the the loss of
funds in the in the dam fund is increase
in cost too as well right not just the
the fall of Revenue but increased costs
yeah you have two things going on
simultaneously the costs are ex
escalating the revenue is decreasing um
has the has the bureau thought about
transferring those high cost dams to
local municipalities so that they don't
have to absorb that cost I know in the
public works Committee in the house they
amended the 10-year Transportation plan
to transfer a road to to the town of
marac that they wouldn't have those
expenses has that been thought of to do
with the dams uh certainly any town of
municipality would like to seek to take
over a dam um that they're certainly
more than welcome to come to the dam
Bureau to do so there are some dams in
the state that I believe the state would
like to retain such as Lake Port Dam at
the AL wnab basaki some of these big
lakes just because of the economic
driver that the the state has with those
bodies of water and the public trust and
other items that go into that that body
of water but certainly um anytime a
municipality or any other entity would
like to take over the dam the the dam
Bureau is always open to that I think
there's also a realization by
municipalities and others that these are
very expensive structures to own operate
maintain and therefore as of right
now they're probably thinking you know
have the state continue doing those
doing the work and the upkeep necessary
at these structures follow up Mr chair
what if what if a municipality didn't
want that damn could the bureau force
them to take it no not currently okay
thank
you thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um I understand sometimes dams are
controlled by uh um different towns
municipalities and but there is an
economic uh flow of that water let's
talk about drought years not today we're
in we're in excessive water years but
when there's not a drought year and if
some Town owns that specific Dam and
they decide to restrict the water can if
they took the dam would they would who
would then manage the water downflow
from that and other lakes that or ponds
that receed that water further
Downstream if they restrict the dam who
manages the Restriction of how much
water flows through the dam if they own
it so from from statutes that affect the
dam bureau there's there's very little
in the way of requiring Downstream flows
uh one of the other Revenue sources that
the dam Bureau does have is we have what
we call water user agreements so uh so
for example water that comes out of Lake
Winn Abasi hydr power producers
Downstream pay a fee to the dam Bureau
for the use of the water coming out of
the lake and so contractually the state
of New Hampshire needs to provide that
that volume of water
um the um that is the only statutory
requirement from the dam buau as far as
discharge there other there are other
programs within Dees such as the
instream flow program that if statute
arily they are required to discharge
water out of a certain water body um we
we work closely with the instream flr
program for example on the lamp River
Watershed if if we hit a drought year
then we have to discharge water at that
point in time but as far as additional
statutes um requiring water to be
discharged those are really the only
ones that I'm familiar with from an
operational standpoint there could be
other ones based on Flowage based on
Deeds uh that sort of thing that you
know someone Downstream could within
their deed have rights to a certain
volume of water out of a water body
thank
you thank you for taking my question I'm
just confused the beginning of these
letters and the bill talks about the
$300 million to really fix the hazard
High Hazard 63 dams and then the bill
goes on to talk about about
declassifying non- Menace dams does this
bill have anything to do with getting
you more money to do the 63 menacing Dam
the portion of the bill that would
address that would be the committee to
to look at other Revenue sources for the
dam Bureau to address those High Hazard
dams so it's just the committee there's
nothing specifically in here that says
you're going to get money from here or
you thank you thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question what's the
impact um of reclassifying a non- menace
Dam to a higher classification what's
the the financial cost or the cost to
the municipalities or something like
that so if if you classify a a So
currently when we have the four
classifications we have high significant
low Hazard and non- Menace the idea
behind a non- Mena dam is should that
Dam fail it's not going to impact
anybody Downstream really the only
people who should know would be the
property
owner if you were to if there was um
someone else's property Downstream or um
a road or some other infrastructure that
would be damaged by failure of that non
menam and we would like to reclassify
that Dam that Dam would then fall into
one of the other categories whether High
significant or low based on those
different categories would be the um
they would become subject to an annual
Dam dam registration fee in which lwh
Hazard dams currently do not pay they
would then become subject to inspection
frequencies and depending on the hazard
classification they they may or may not
be required to develop an emergency
action plan all high and significant
Hazard dams require an emergency action
not
anyone any other questions by members of
the
committee let's see just said one one
question if uh do you get any
contributions from people who have land
of residences or property uh out on the
lake side of the dam uh to help to help
keep upkeep of the dam the only the only
Revenue that we get from residents
around the lake occurs at very few water
bodies Goose pond dam and Canan because
the state of New Hampshire actually owns
the rim
of that water body so if you live if you
have property on goosepond the state of
New Hampshire actually owns a sliver of
that and we lease that to the property
owner for their
use and um and there's a couple others
uh Lake Francis in Pittsburgh Dees owns
around the entire water body we lease
Camp Lots up there uh Horus Lake over in
we there's I think nine lots that we
lease and um a couple others uh deing
res where there's one
um lake winnisquam has uh several on the
canal leading up to the dam but overall
I'm talking you know just a couple dozen
leases that actually generate Revenue
into uh the dam maintenance fund as well
other than that there's no other outside
source so for example Lake winnes the
dam does not receive any income from
anything that occurs around the rim of
that Lake as far as directly into our
my got to ask you in a different way
they're benefiting from the existence of
the dam all the people behind the dam
have places and homes and mult some
million dollar homes there and there's
no way that they can that uh that they
would contribute if the dam was needed
to be uh needed to be upgraded or needed
to needed work they would not be
required to be contributed uh
then what if you took the dam away what
would happen
then uh that there is a way of getting
rid of dams yes and you know maybe maybe
it's just me who doesn't own anything on
the on the water that so it's the
nobody is considering asking for uh
contributions to by the by the people
around the dams in the back of the dam
to contribute to the front of the dam to
fix
it so nobody's there's no no no no ask
on that well there's certainly no um
Reven there's no there's no law there's
no yeah there's no requirement for that
to occur obviously will you know
donations or other grants or anything
like that we always seeking different
ways of generating Revenue but yes
currently there is no requirement for us
to gather funds from those um people
living around the impoundment that is
generated by the dam thank you president
Darcy Darby that's thank you Mr chair
thanks again for taking my question um
representative mcon expressed some
slight concerns about the um the time
frame of the committee completion at the
end at the beginning of November um I
believe in your testimony you said that
you know you want it was important that
the committee were able to take action
do you have similar concerns about the
compressed time frame of this committee
and able to in its ability to to have uh
impactful results in a few months well
we certainly want to get the best
benefit as we can out of out of the the
committee if it was formed and so um if
if uh this committee feels that it would
be beneficial to to come back at a later
date or different time un which we could
have um more time to get this right then
the dam Bureau would be certainly
um we would support that because we we
want to make sure that it gets right and
if if if trying to squeeze it into too
tight of a time frame um impacts that
then yeah we would
certainly okay representative
Veil um thank you for taking my question
I just um looking at the um Dam
maintenance Hydro funds there I wanted
to just make sure this is a non-aps fund
that we're talking about in
section two of the
bill yes correct yeah thank
you
any more questions they're being seeing
no more
questions thank you very
much uh that's it for the uh 549 far as
pink
cards so
I'll declare the hearing ajour and we're
minutes
hey maybe I'll come back so I can just
harass the
people
Lake
should
e
this and get out of
second Senator
bzel it
is the floor is
yours
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
for hearing um my Prime bill Senate Bill
589 for the record my name is Regina
burzell I'm state senator for district
19 which encompasses the towns of dairy
Hamstead and
Windham and I believe I was um a couple
of years ago I had put in a bill very
similar to this um this is uh this was
requested by the town of dairy
and what what it does thank you what it
does
um it basically it's the objective is
this bill is to allocate funds generated
from the sech charge towards Economic
Development initi initiatives in the
town um on waste water we did something
very similar similar to this in 2021 and
you have a a letter that the town um
administrator Dave Karen had written but
what we did is is um up until that
period of time the water that went
through um to Dairy was um 100% of it
was supposed to be um just for the
maintenance of the um the water system
well there were millions of there was a
lot of money in that um in that account
and it was more than enough to uh there
was more than enough in that account to
go ahead and continue maintaining it so
what they had asked to do is um have
about 15% of that be able to be put
towards uh economic development in the
town and we did pass it and it's been
it's really been a boom boom to Dairy
and we're asking for this a similar
situation with the
Wastewater um they have um a lot of the
waste waterer uh runs through Dairy and
um they as uh Karen said the dairy Town
Council supports London dairy's efforts
to Maxim maximize the development along
the exit 4A Corridor it allows a 15%
surcharge on outof Town Wastewater
customers it provides modest Revenue
stream for dairies so it does very
similar to the bill that we passed in
2021 and I ask for your support on uh
Senate Bill
589 and I'll take any questions okay any
thank you Mr chair uh thank you senator
for taking my question if I understand
the the language in um part three of
this um with respect to um
municipalities governed under RSA 49
d3i that would only apply to towns and
not to cities in terms of how they can
um spend the um the Sur charge is that
is that the intent that is my
understanding but I I think
um there are others behind me that can
answer that a little bit more
appropriately but I believe so just
you any other questions by members of
the committee seeing we ALS we also have
one of the town councilors from da here
um Brian chello that will um be able to
um Talk a little bit about the benefits
of what's happened in Dairy
energy good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee uh Josh Elliott I am
the director of the division of policy
and programs for the New Hampshire dep
Department of energy um if you're
confused as to why I'm here rather yes
um so under the statutes the department
of energy also oversees regulation of
water and sewer systems that are reg
that are considered regulated utilities
um so the statute actually here that's
being amended is part of the statutes of
the Department of energy
overseas the um the bill in question U
makes that change um that Senator Burell
spoke to uh about allowing uh
essentially municipality to go beyond
their own town boundaries um and not be
considered a public utility provided
that they only charge uh less than 15%
above what the in town rate is uh for
whatever reason and I can't say to why
this is true this allowance was made for
Water Systems so if you're transporting
drinking water across town lines you're
able to do this for whatever reason the
statute never allowed for waste water to
for the same ability so for example if
you had a town municipally runed uh
sewer system they wanted to extend to
the next town over uh if they charged
anything more than what they charged
their own in town customers they would
then be considered a regulated utility
and then their rates would be um uh set
by the Public Utilities Commission
rather than by the voters or or or
commission within the
community so we think this allowance is
completely reasonable and matches with
existing statute provides for the uh
Drinking Water Systems the department
did request um and we'd like to thank
Senator Burell for for doing this uh
section two of the bill um as amended by
the Senate um adds two very important
words um later in the statute um that
you'll see the bolded language on lines
12 and 13 that just add or SE um as you
may be aware the department of energy is
a recent Creation in the last two and a
half years uh that was created through
the budget process we're in the process
of taking all what had been Public
Utilities Commission rules and bringing
them over to the Department of energy
as part of that we've been looking at
the water and the sewer rules and the uh
current uh rule structure um makes it
clear that Community sewer systems so
for example if you have a condo
association or homeowners association
where there's essentially communal um
sewer system that's not connected as
part of a town or something like that
that's just sort of within within the
development um we do not consider them a
public utility uh as going through the
gel car process um for establishing
rules the Jael car staff disagreed with
our interpretation um that this statute
would also for allow um the um for the
consideration of those Community Systems
to not be considered public
utilities they disagreed with that
initial interpretation they had
requested that we seek this change from
the legislature to make it very clear in
that statute that both water and sewer
systems of the for these Community
associations are not considered public
utilities um I think uh I can speak for
both the department and the Public
Utilities Commission that we have no
interest in regulating these little
Community sewer systems um this would
just be purely on a financial basis we
have no interest in doing that there's
no reason to do that there's no purpose
of doing
that I will just add that this does not
change any of the regulations that our
colleagues at the department
environmental services does so all the
environmental regulations that currently
apply to these systems continue to apply
to these systems it's just we are not
going to regulate them making it clear
in the statute that we are not going to
regulate them on a financial
basis any questions by members of the
committee representative Dar thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um so I understand that um um
der is you know requested this bill are
there other towns that take advantage of
um of the E extra funds for selling
water out of um out of their District
currently I I will confess I'm not an
expert on this um I am not aware of any
okay thank
you that's all
thanks anyone a question by anyone uh
else from the
committee thank you very much thank you
very
much honorable Brian
cherell
D yes good afternoon Mr chairman
committee members my name is Brian
chirichello I'm a Dar Town counselor I
can give you a little bit of perspective
as to um some of the backstory of the of
why we're here for this bill um as
Senator birdell mentioned um back a
couple of years ago we were approached
by um the Senate Senator Morse by the
way um looking to wield water through
Derry um Windam Salem plastow eventually
getting to plastow because plastow
needed some water um and so um we worked
together with the then Senate President
um the state paid for the the
infrastructure to wield this water uh
and we were able to um you know charge
uh for the the water going through to
our uh our our neighbors to the South um
what's important to know is more and
more the the communities in our area are
really kind of looking to regionalize
some things we want to share resources
if we can um and if you look at if you
if you knew where dairy was and where
their their sewer system is
located um and you've probably all heard
about Exit 4
a the new exit off of um
93 you'd know that it's it's like right
over the line is it's very close this
the sewer system of dairies uh and the
development of London dairies so um it
makes sense um to help our neighboring
towns where we can uh the only thing is
is obviously we' we'd have to you know
we we need to benefit as well so that's
where the extra charge would
be um So currently der's wielding water
to the you know the five communities
south of us all the way to plastal and
now one der is asking us for sewer
capacity which we have in Derry and
we're willing to share because again
sharing resources is really what it's
all about so I'm happy to answer any
questions that anyone has about how that
established anybody uh have a question
oh okay he can put his own
hand thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh so I understand
that this bill is uh really helping out
Dairy and lary would could this possibly
expand into other towns and other towns
could actually expand if they wanted to
with this you know Elevate you know
passing this bill opens the opportunity
for other towns too correct yes
representative that's
that's that's exactly right it doesn't
specify Dairy lond andair other
communities can use it and I hope that
they do because again we're sharing
resources you know we're saving we're
saving Londoner some money Londoner can
actually build their infrastructure and
send it up to Manchester but it's very
very costly so again where location is
and we you know sharing resources it's
great because um as you probably well
know with Tusk and kitchen that
development there this this one here
Woodmont Orchards is actually a little
bit bigger in size um the process may
take a little bit longer but you know
it's it's going to be an economic bone
for that area along with the exit the
new exit off of
93 so I think I think other communities
could use
it representative
Darby thank thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my
question um the so Wastewater systems as
I think we heard earlier um in other
bills are EXP ensive to maintain but it
sounds like you're trying to take the
goal is to take some of these funds and
put them to other um to other
development purposes and that's I I
understood you that's that's the benefit
that der's going to receive from this
yeah
so if you if you look at a town budget
typically water and waste water what we
call Enterprise funds they're typically
for the for the people that use them
they're not a general fund uh money so
um with the water example if we're
wielding water to the south of us and
it's we're charging x amount per water
flow you can see that we're going to
actually in perpetuity we're going to
we'll have a lot of money so technically
without the bill that Senator bdel put
in to actually be able to use some of
that that Enterprise money it had to
stay in that particular
fund so um we had asked uh uh Senator
birdell to to put in a bill which would
allow us to use some some of that money
for economic development so it's really
a win-win for the town of Derry we're
helping our our sister towns but then we
were using some of that money to um use
for economic development in the
town you Mr thank you Mr chair um on a
followup is there um if there were
problems with the Wastewater system for
example the capacity was exceeded over
time you know is there is there
potential that because these funds were
not a available that you'd have to dip
into get uh State funding or something
like that in order to support um you
know revitalizing the waste an over
taxed Wastewater
system uh I so I'm going to you know the
wording says the inter Municipal
agreement so it really depends on the
legality of the wording there I mean I
know that the the state put in for the
water now going back to the water they
put the the state put the infrastructure
in um but eventually 50 years down the
road Maybe the town would have to fix
fix the those those um infrastructure
pieces so it would be wise for my my
water department basically would set
aside some monies knowing full well that
eventually down the road we'd have to
make some of those repairs I think I
answered the
question
okay representative
wolf thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um is there any
possibility that it's some some point
down the road you would run out of
capacity or Supply if it's the water
capacity on the
swer so if we're talking about the water
side of things I think the state has a
plan that they've actually utilized um
for water right now D gets its water
from Lake Massabesic which is
Manchester's water um water source and a
few other towns but I believe the state
has invested in in some water projects
off of the ma River to actually keep the
the the flow at a you know we're not
going to run out of water anytime soon
um as far as the the the sewer portion
of that we we understand our capacity of
what we have uh and we have planners
that that are looking at where our
buildout is der's you know der's a third
uh fourth largest community in the state
we have 35,000 people we we kind of know
where the plans are for future so
whatnot so before we make made that
decision we we understand where we're at
and we're comfortable uh with the
have anyone
much
Mike uh you just pronounced your last
name thank you Mr chair Mike
malagi I'm the town manager in
londondary okay um Mr chairman members
of the Comm thank you for uh um
considering this bill today um I'm here
to report that London der supports this
uh legislation and I'm grateful to those
uh who have spoken uh earlier and who
have sponsored this bill including
senators berel and Carson um just to
Echo some of the comments that have been
made uh and Orient everyone to the area
uh that we're talking about this is uh
part of the Woodmont comments develop
planned unit development it straddles
i93 um and uh we're talking specifically
here about the east side of 93 um that's
approximately 200 Acres which according
to the master plan for this plan unit
development um entails uses of vital
importance both to London Derry but also
to the regional and state economy um and
that includes 350 residential units
420,000 and 300 uh beds of institutional
use uh no limit limit on Civic uses a
200 bed hotel and 700,000 uh Square ft
of commercial uh use all of these come
um with a significant sewer demand and
uh hence why we are here today um the uh
really um what what I would suggest to
the committee is in order to realize the
promise of that mixed use plan uh that
really is inherent in the Woodmont
commment uh development um we we need to
secure additional sewer capacity and as
Mr chello said we could invest in that
by building
uh a long pipe to Manchester at a a
significant uh significantly greater
expense um but we've been fortunate
enough to uh have good relations with
our neighbors in Derry um and uh and and
and that has uh has brought us here
today um I would just point out a couple
of things one is that it's not automatic
um so this this legislation would not
automatically increase rates uh to
anyone that needs to occur pursuant to
an intermunicipal agreement agement uh
and as been as has been pointed out we
do have a intermunicipal agreement with
the uh town of Derry it has Provisions
for what happens if we run out of
capacity what happens if there are uh
required infrastructure upgrades uh
London Derry participates in those
upgrades um that may be required in the
future um according to the proportion uh
that it is rece it is sending uh sewer
sewer flows to Dairy um M Mr chair
members of the committee I suggest that
this uh presents communities with uh
opportunities to cooperate um
opportunities for additional uh choice
and flexibility um and really londondary
supports this because it is a relatively
modest payment that will yield millions
of dollars of tax revenue um and those
badly needed uses uh that I mentioned
earlier so again in closing I want to
thank uh the dairy Town Administrator
the dairy Town Council um and the
Senators that I mentioned uh for
supporting this legislation and I'm
happy to take any of the committee's
questions anyone uh from the committee
any
chair I out of pink
cards unless there's someone
uh who wants to want to speak I'm going
to end the I'm going to end
home hearing is over
yes I'm go
home all right
highway all right all right members of
the
committee